good evening members
um
a gender item one is Chairman's notices
this is the usual
when I can find them the usual notice is
that
we have uh good evening and welcome to
the meeting of the Council on the 50
15th of December 2022. my name is
councilor Boyce and I'm the chairman of
the council
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put up your hand to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent upon the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when you're invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contribution as
clear and concise as possible as we've
got a long agenda tonight
thank you
a gender item two apologies for absence
uh Miss bird
and Captain Morgan thank you chairman
now Council settle uh yeah there should
have been apologies from councilor Mays
as well councilor Mays
um I think councilor Ann Beale has
sent her apologies
uh councilor Thompson Council
Council of white
uh
here she is right
um
agenda item three
the minutes of the 3rd of November on
pages 7 to 14 to confirm the minutes of
the council meeting held on the 3rd of
November and the copy is enclosed
do we accept those minutes
thank you
um
a gender item four minutes of the third
of November 2022 extraordinary meeting
contained on pages 15 to 18 to confirm
the minutes of the extraordinary council
meeting held on the 3rd of November 2022
and there's copying close you agree
those minutes
is that is that unanimous thank you
um agenda item
five Declaration of interest to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph nine and appendix B
of the code of conduct for members
members are also reminded they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
is there any interest
later
thank you chairman it's regarding one of
the um items under PNC and it's um
oh sorry can you hear me now
uh sorry I'll take that off then for
that but it's regarding one of the items
under PNC chairman a gender item 19a I
wish to declare an interesting as much
shown I'm not quite sure it's other or
none however if a certain item comes up
well I won't identify and obviously in
this session
um that I declare now that I'm a member
of a charity organization called Crohn's
and Colitis UK and should a matter come
up I I will be leaving the chambers as a
certain item that might be related to
that I will leave the chamber for that
item chairman if it comes an item of
discussion thank you thank you leader uh
was there somebody else
now then we go on to a gender item six
public questions have we had any from
the public Miss Byrd
no Kevin we've got none thank you
agenda item seven Chairman's
announcements
um
the last two weeks I've
been very busy
visiting graveyards the last two
Saturdays
I've spent two or three hours in
Sub-Zero temperatures
in in modern Cemetery
uh to for the the annual dedication of
the natural burial site there which is
one of
uh the cemetery teams
uh some very very much success
and naming on a tree in haybridge
Cemetery
I also had the pleasure to host a party
at the plume school for Ukrainian
children last Monday
that was a delight thank you members
Gemma can I
um raise the point of order with you I
know you're going to ask me what number
it is and I've forgotten but it's the
one that deals with the length of of
meeting chairman and in particular the
cutoff time at 10 30. can I propose
Chairman's Council that we don't take
any business after 10 pm tonight unless
we're confident that it can be dealt
with by 10 30. Gem and I say that
because the forecast tonight is minus
six and I said a lot of us have got to
go to work in the morning me included
and chairman apart from anything else
without even saying that Jim we should
also think about the staff and in
particular those that are involved in
private and confidential items which
could potentially run on to goodness
knows when thank you chairman
um that the point of order there is
um
uh in the Constitution that the meeting
lasts from 9 30 till 10 30. so
um
you're partly right I would hope we can
finish by 9 30.
UM however uh it will be the Chairman's
discretion as to what time the the
meeting finishes
I'm aiming I hope we're all aiming for
at the most 10 30. thank you
um
yeah
right then we go on to a gender item
eight the minute book to consider the
recommendations coming from the
Committees and we have a strategy and
resources Committee of the 10th of
November contained on pages 19 to 38.
um Miss White
but thank you Mr chairman uh yes we have
um two recommendations the
recommendations are little one the
appendix that the detailed fees and
charges for 2023 2024 are set out in
appendix eight these minutes be agreed
and little two that the inflation rate
be applied to those fees and charges as
detailed at appendix B to these minutes
now before we go to discussion or
ratification do I have a poser and a
second of this
okay uh thank you very much members
um okay so um
over to you Mr chairman for
um discussion
um
councilor fluka
I just want to be absolutely sure but my
agree in this recommendation we aren't
going to hop tie ourselves later when we
get to considering uh other issues
um I see what the report says but some
of these issues do uh link and because
of that chairman I'm just a tad
concerned that if we agree these all
together
um that we might find that we've already
made a decision into relation to what
we're going to be considering afterwards
and I believe that if we make this
decision the six month war will apply
thank you Ms White
um I'm in your hands it's not my
decision to make I don't think
um
there's a proposal to agree the
recommendation that's been proposed and
seconded those in favor please show
do somebody counting
whichever
it's dangerous this is very dangerous
those against
one two three four
um that is carried then
um thank you Miss White agenda item nine
uh minutes of the meeting of the council
there's a list there
is there any questions under six two
uh councilor Fluker thank you chairman I
just wanted to uh bring members
attention to the the minutes of uh
performance governance and all and on
particular the meeting of the 17th sorry
uh which of those listed are you
referring to sorry chairman and maybe I
wasn't speaking loud enough a moment ago
when I said performance governance and
orders it's the third from the bottom
17th of November that's excellent
obviously my microphone is working yeah
the 17th of November um chairman in in
particular I think it's page 70 odd but
the summary of work that was carried out
by the internal audit team and and it
speaks to the uh the amendments to their
plan and in particular uh and and
chairman I'm mindful of what I'm going
to say that the words I'm referring to
now were said in public session at that
meeting
and it it goes on to say it talks about
cyber security uh which will provide
further assistance on the work completed
following the the attempted fraud
now
I know about a Cyber attack I think the
committee referred to that as a scam
um but now we've been it's been talked
about by fraud so I wonder if the
chairman of the committee and I'm sorry
for putting it in a difficult position
not least of all that we spoke today
um but I wonder if we could have some
more information about this and why the
core of this information bearing in mind
I believe the police investigation is
finished is being well withheld from the
public there's a lot of public interest
in this chairman uh thank you councils
Luca uh uh councilor stamp
um
we yeah
I'm going to say thank you chairman it's
the first that it's been brought to my
attention about this very subject I
think it's a little bit unfair that it's
actually just landed on my doorstep
without me having a chance to actually
read the minutes again to review what it
what was actually said I can't take it
from you now cancer fluke with it so can
I ask that it is deferred and brought up
to the next meeting and we just don't
don't agree with those minutes because
there's no way I can actually say yes
you can give a written response
to all members it goes to all members
yes okay I'm happy to do that with
respect I think my question was also
leveled at the officers in relations
will be recorded well it is being
recorded because somebody's just told me
to speak up but they like the question
but
um I think it's important that we Now
understand from CLT why this information
has been suppressed and and I look
forward to seeing that written response
to all members tomorrow morning chairman
because I don't think it will be
tomorrow morning
thank you
uh we'll still be sit with at this rate
we'll still be sitting here tomorrow
morning
um a gender item 10 notice of motions uh
now
um I I've allowed these uh motions to
appear on the um on the agenda Council
Fluker as it's Christmas
um
but also that if the uh one two and
three motions uh were
referred to relevant committees
uh or further reports that we have later
on
um it would have made a nonsense of your
motion for because the the public which
you're being transparent
uh for won't have a clue what the motion
for was talking about
Motion One
it will be considered in the resolution
to to retreat the report as exempt
information and be dealt with as private
and confidential
uh and you can therefore present your
motion at the point on a gender item 18
in connection with agenda item 19a
motion 2 relates to a gender item 12.
which the motion which is to reduce the
sras although agenda item 12 has a
recommendation for change in members
allowances from May this does not
prevent prevent you Council Fluker
presenting this motion as part of the
revision to members allowances it would
seem part and parcel of a review of both
basic and special responsibility
allowances
motion three this forms part of the
savings items that agenda item 19a which
contains rejected savings options of
page 147 of the pack this motion can be
put at this point
motion four I think I've actually
answered but you do have the right to
continue with that motion at the moment
thank you very much Kevin and can I say
that's exactly what I was expecting you
to say and I'm grateful that you did
because the motions have been public
published now and and I'm I'm certainly
harmful chairman by the responses where
I've had for members of the public
concerning
um and I think motion fortune in the
past there has been some confusion about
my emotions going forward although I
understand from the LGA it may well have
been because of the way I vote them but
I don't actually remember anybody
telling me here that they weren't
written properly but if anybody needs it
if I'm having difficulty hearing
Newcastle zoy chairman and I think so is
the whole of South Minster so German the
motion four was really just too we were
District councilors sorry chairman can I
just remind you that I'm the Democratic
representative of South Minster Ward
first and then a district councilor and
that's exactly how the people of South
Minister understand it and have done for
the last 11 and a half years and I wish
them all well for Christmas so I think
chairman
um you know the the the reason for
motion four was really chairman to make
sure that this was dealt with openly and
transparency and and and can I thank you
for doing just that so I'll withdraw the
motion thank you thank you can we then
move on
um we're doing we're doing well uh
members questions uh in the columnsford
procedure rule six three which notice
has been given
um uh Miss bird I take it there has been
none
thank you a gender item 12 reporter The
Independent remuneration panel contained
on pages 43 to 72 leader
thank you very much chairman
um
this is obviously as the report is
titled independent manual review members
allowances and it's uh the fact they did
review the members allowances chairman
on the 15th of August 2022.
um and it's because there is good
practice actually to review every few
years the allowances and mechanism for
increases and benchmarking was a part of
the process and members can see that
within their pack there is also member
survey conducted I'm sure many members
will appreciate that had the opportunity
to take participate in that survey and I
um I'm sure a great number of members
did
um the independent review panel agreed
removal of the Broadband allowance they
did make reference to that but they also
indicated
um certain exceptions regarding that
financial hardship and the independent
review panel also placed an emphasis on
diversity and money from removal of
broadband allowances to support
maternity policy which they have
recommended in line with other
authorities
um
and it's also to say Jim and they also
were quite clear they did not recommend
any deviation from the agreeing uplift
in line with the percentage increase of
staff
and I draw members attention to the
implications impact on equalities
um regarding
um the promotion of equality in terms of
uh the report
and also the reflection on strength in
communities allowing more to access
becoming a member
chairman the recommendations therefore
are as on the order paper the little one
to little three and I'll read them out
if you like little one that the council
supports the recommendation of the
independent remuneration panel the
members allowances will increase in line
with the average staff pay increases
from 2023 a set out in section 3.6 below
little two that Broadband allowance
payment is withdrawn from April 2023 and
nickel three that the types of expenses
that members can claim be detailed in
the new members allowance policy under
approved duties section of appendix one
and I think that's helpful actually for
all members chairman and nickel Ford the
newly drafted members allowance policy
appendix one and maternity paternity
shared parental leave and adoption
policy
appendix to our adopted chairman and I
will move those recommendations if it
helps the debate second is an amendment
please
um
I don't think you can second and then
move
an amendment at this stage and uh as
councilor siddle second did it you can
move an amendment
thank you very much
um thank you chairman I propose that we
add a fifth recommendation which would
be that we refer this um
special responsibility allowances to the
independent remuneration panel to deal
with that since they are independent and
they are in a position then to look at
everything because there's at least one
very busy and active position that has
no allowance and others that I think
could do with some review and indeed
some may be revised downwards but that's
that's my proposal as a extra
recommendation is that seconded
yep all right um uh I assume I assume
that you uh when you put your hand up
council is local you weren't second in
uh that uh
goodness I I thought it was only the
monitoring officer that could read my
mind but clearly you can as well can I
speak now please do yeah thank you
chairman um look you know I take a
certain amount of you know we're we're
dealing with the uh with the motion and
the Amendments we are indeed chairman so
so can you just give me some guidance
over what you meant by motion
well when when the leader proposed
um uh the recommendations I think it was
councilor siddle that second did uh
um that so that then is was a
substantive motion we're now debating
the amendment that councilor Thompson uh
has uh
um uh asked for
okay I'm great for a few Gardens so I
mean obviously when the word motion is
mentioned it conjures up all sorts of
things in my mind
um chairman I I there is something you
know flawed in this this report I'm
grateful for the enumeration panel for
what they've done but I think we do have
to look at some of these figures
particularly the comparison and where
you've actually where you've got
cabinets and where you haven't got
cabinets and of course one has to accept
that cabinet members tend to make
executive decisions which we don't in a
committee system but there are clearly
some issues here I mean PGA and SNR
they're due to me I think six times
according to the calendar next year
which would mean that the chairman would
receive 904 pounds in allowances for
each meeting and and 384 pound for the
vice chairman which is a huge amount of
money chairman you know I you know I I
know how much I earn and I know how much
I I have to work for it but I mean 904
pounds and and yes of course someone's
going to say yes but we we have agenda
meetings Okay so that brings us down to
500 pound the meeting and then we're
working groups well it seems to me that
it seems to be the same cohort of
members that are on all the working
groups at this Council so just because
you're a chairman you go to a working
group the likelihood is you were likely
to go to it even if you weren't the
chairman or the vice chairman so clearly
there is something that's not quite like
with all of this chairman
um my main concern is Chairman that if
we were to agree to these
recommendations now
uh and the the deputy leaders uh
suggestion
um which I suspect was burned on by my
own motion because I would have thought
that the conservative group would have
looked at these costs and thought this
is not sustainable but clearly they
didn't until I put a motion in
um but what concerns me enormously is if
we agree these recommendations now and
the amendment then when we come to talk
to members announced later on when there
is a recommendation from officers and
the tier two managers to reduce reduce
members announce then we can't do that
because we've made a we've made a
decision now based on these
recommendations so perhaps you could
give me some guidance on that because I
don't think we should have tie ourselves
um I think I think the motion uh is
um correct and I think the amendment is
correct which is uh what we're debating
um
I've got councilor Darren next
thank you do you require me to stand
chairman or not well please I will yes
um well chairman I I look I just want to
say that that
local authorities rely on an independent
enumeration panel to assess the work
that councilors do and it is completely
objective working out
um the amount of hours that they put in
and you know I I think that we we should
adopt the figures that they've put
forward
um I also I don't have a big problem
with the special responsibility
allowances and responsibility here is
the key word I recall this the chairman
of what was Community Services back then
and was now at SNR there is a
considerable amount of responsibility
that goes with that particular post
because you're required to make in in
cooperation with mem with officers some
quite significant decisions on behalf of
this Authority
um I might just say that that Essex
County Council also had a remuneration
review via the independent enumeration
panel that was put to uh full Council to
make the decision and full Council
accepted that the liberal Democrat
opposition to a man voted against it but
it now transpires all but one actually
took the the allowance so it would be my
suggestion Jim if a member doesn't want
to take the uplift they're not obliged
to take it so um as I said that was the
offer given that Essex County Council
but those that voted against the uplift
in the main ended up taking it anyway so
thank you very much chairman uh
councilman
thank you chair um
as just as a point to note as chair of
District planning there is no special
allowance and nor would I take one even
if there was one
um I see that Mr council fluter is as a
duty and an honor and a privilege a
couple of things about the reports you
saw we'll look at the clarity before I
make a determination on whether to
support or not there's um I'm 3.3 on
page 43 we talked about the the what is
the legal and agreed definition of
financial hardship because within the
paper that supported the appendix
um I'd like to see how that's worked out
what the determination of that is and
how it's calculated and also the member
came through who was suffering uh
financial hardship how um what
information will be needed because
you're talking a very very personal
information coming through
um also the the paternity and maternity
policies for members it does seem to be
a good idea
um
maybe for other members
yeah I I I
well you know bless us all
um I get very uncomfortable about taking
leave as a member I think when we stand
as members and we we went out and canvas
we stood for something and the trust was
was given to us so I say this very much
as a 365 days a year 24 7 job
um that I wouldn't take leave unless I
was seriously seriously ill
um so I I do struggle a little bit about
that
uh and and finally
um again I think um Council fluka
um mentioned it in the paper that
supports it in the members allowance
scheme under 10.5 it talks about
approved duties and it goes on the
functions of the Authority or any of its
committees or subcommittees outlined as
follows in a member's capacity as a
chair Vice chair Cabinet member
or official opposition group on a
committee or cabinet function attendance
at a meeting with officers discuss
matters associated with the
responsibilities of the committee or the
cabinet I'm very uncomfortable with that
detail because we're not a cabinet-run
council so I'm not I'm not convinced
that the detail is is here
and I I find it very um
strange that we would be talking about a
cabinet when we don't have a cabinet so
that's just the observations
thank you chairman
um the independent remuneration panel
recommended that if the Broadband
allowance was removed that some money be
set aside for hardship
um obviously at the moment that is it's
very discretionary there isn't a scheme
proposed around this it's a set of money
that it can be put aside and available
and potentially could come forward at
the moment
um for a formal agreement I suppose in
terms of the maternity paternity policy
uh probably on your point to the prime
minister of New Zealand who took some
time out from her role due to maternity
um leave around that factor
um I think in terms of the
um in terms of the
expenses policy then we surveyed members
and whether the definition should be
strengthened
um I think at the moment it says
official duties
um on it so there is a move actually if
we strengthen that that is a definition
that's coming down and there potentially
could be some areas that could could
fall outside of that I think at the
moment is very much linked to a
direction of the council so if it's
Council directed activities that is
accessible if not
um then that could potentially fall
outside the remit so I think it's a
decision for members around the expenses
policy if they feel actually the current
word in official duties is sufficiently
flexible
um to allow expenses to be reclaimed or
if indeed there is a tighter
policy which is outlined in the report
or if they want to make
recommended changes to that so really
for members to decide um if they feel
that current wording of official duties
is actually sufficient and flexible or
if based on the survey there is
something more strict and with clearer
guidelines to come in
a very briefly councilor lager thank you
chair I hope that that does answer some
of your questions absolutely not share
none of my questions have been answered
all right thank you I just want that
record so the the questions were raised
that the the statements are fair Mr
Leslie but you haven't answered any of
the questions I'm afraid
uh councilor settle
uh thank you chairman I'd just like to
back up what some of what councilor
Durham said uh in terms of the
allowances and I know from my own
experience as chairman of SNR that it's
not just things that we do in that
position in the council but it's also
all the work and the working groups that
we attend outside the council and
when we go to those so maybe this is
answers Council lagan's question you're
going to that meeting
as a Cabinet member because you're
representing that part of the the
council no no no no so so in inverted
commas because the other people who are
attending that meeting from other
authorities that may have a cabinet are
the same people as our committee chairs
and I and I I I don't like that wording
in but that's maybe why that wording is
there
in in 2018
before I was elected apparently there
was a need for a transformation a need
for a lot of cuts because of the
financial difficulties that this Council
was under at that particular time the
lead of the council was councilor fluka
and I don't remember him putting forward
this motion at that particular time when
when he was the leader of this this
Council and from what I remember in
terms of looking before I got elected I
looked at how much the leader was taken
I think it was around about 20 000
pounds including all his expenses so I
really find it quite ironic that
councilor fluke has brought forward his
motion at this particular time and I
think it's a little bit of
electioneering on his part
people herself against the fault good
value okay
um you know the leader has the right to
sum up so I'll go to councilor Bell
first
thank you um Mr chairman I have a number
of issues
um I'm not that well off I take this
role very seriously and when I took it
on I had to give up a significant amount
of my freelance work in order to do the
role properly
do I think that allowances should be
linked with a number of meetings people
attend the amount they put into the work
role yes I do but that's not on the
table
in terms of diversity cost of living is
going to affect everybody
not just people who are having children
so I think actually I don't think it's
going to increase diversity putting the
money from the Broadband allowance into
a maternity adoption policy my
broadband's going up by 60 quid a year
next year and you want to remove the
allowance that pays for that
I have some problems with this thank you
Miss Bell I noticed you sorry counselor
Bell I noticed you
got an arm problem I hope all is well
thank you it was a snowboarding accident
Mr chairman
uh Council of Swain
um thank you chairman um this is a bit
confusing
um
I thought we would um debate
Council Thompson's Amendment separately
from the rest connected with the
remuneration panel but we've seen
Council Swain I did explain with the
motion the the leader's motion and the
amendment in one debate
yes but it's a bit complicated I'm I
mean I've only had one or two comments
on the main
substance of the motion but I do have a
comment on the special allowances and I
I disagree with what has been said
um about the the need for it the basic
allowance which I have to say I wasn't
aware of really when I was elected
um and I certainly wasn't aware that it
was a special responsibility allowance
when I became a vice chairman of SNR
um but the basic allowances what it is
and there's a procedure for him updating
that but
um the special responsibilities
allowance seems to me that you don't
have to have it
um if you don't have to take on these
special responsibilities if you
um don't want to
um and uh
if if you want to do that if you put
yourself forward as a for a leading role
a chairmanship I mean you recognize you
are doing that so you can contribute
more in that in that role so I mean that
is something that would have been
debated later on the other
it matters in the substantive motion
um
first of all I can see the Broadband
allowance shouldn't be a sort of um
across the board thing it should be for
individual or special cases
um and uh the to the extent that it's
withdrawn and put into this promotion of
diversity I would like to have some idea
whether uh it actually would amount to
much in practice
um I have one question on the actual
wording of the um up the bit concerning
adoption
um the way it's worded
um it it refers to uh special leave on
birth or adoption
which seems to imply adoption of very
young children but people adopt older
children
um isn't it the same
um
reason for special allowances it's maybe
in the wording that um
uh thank you Council Swain uh Council
Fluker I'm sorry I think you wanted to
bring up a point of personal explanation
well yes I did I mean my first question
is is really good question uh you I
thought you indicated you had a uh to
query something councilor siddle said
and you had a good Channel because you
know one chairman I'm I'm delighted to
know that he was stalking my expenses
before I even came on this but gem you
got if you wind back three and a half
years and look you know my my expenses
for that period are part of a public
record and you will see you know I can
remember going to meetings every day
sometimes twice a day and I was driving
all around the county and that's
reflected in my mileage I mean I
goodness knows
um the value of my car must have dropped
10 grand because I put an extra 20 000
miles on it one year but chairman times
have changed and I made that clear in my
motion that most of these meetings now
are done by teams so it doesn't take up
you know it's so much time you know
maybe in the interests of everybody the
people that receive a special
responsibility ability allowances leave
their Diaries open their corporate dies
in so we can see what they're up to and
I'm sure that if they're doing more
exciting mine is always open to anybody
that wants to have a look well Tim and I
know you're one of the most open and
transparent members of this Council and
I'm grateful not only are we neighbors
Jim your card's out outside
um councilor
Stan
yeah thank you chairman
um I'll be brief for a change
um I actually think that by
um stopping the Broadband allowance
you're actually denying people on a low
income it is broadband costs a lot of
money it's only cost me a lot of money
especially in the in the stakes to get a
fast fast speed and I think you're
actually then stopping people like
councilor Bell said and I totally agree
which is very rare with councilor Durham
uh that yeah very rare Essex and here in
the fact that if members don't want the
special allowances why don't them hand
them back and go to the special fund to
help people if they are suffering a
financial difficulty surely that makes
more sense and the people who do need it
people's Financial conditions change
chairman all the time unless you know
unless you're quite wealthy and I don't
think some people in this chamber maybe
are wealthy and there's others that
aren't chairman so I think it's down to
the individuals and I think we should
vote accordingly
um thank you
um we're going around on second calls
now but councilor Durham and councilor
uh Thompson I just really actually I'll
just say thank you very much councilor
uh councilor stamp um it's nice to agree
on something
um all I wanted to say chairman chairman
is is look I didn't know there was an
allowance when before I stood and it was
a surprise the first you know when I was
after my bank account details not an
unpleasant surprise but nobody does this
for the money if they do they're deluded
because if you worked out how much you
get per hour you'd be better stacking
shells in oldie or little inris I I
actually agree that the the the
um special allowance of broadband is
actually a bit outdated because it was
introduced many years ago before there
was widespread use of broadband and it
was put there to encourage people to pay
the extra for Broadband I very much
doubt that anybody here hasn't got
Broadband it's now part of an everyday
necessity so I do support that big drop
councilor Thompson and then councilman
yeah
thank you chairman um you know I was
going to mention the broadcast the
Broadband allowance and I did put in
fact in the survey that I think most of
us by and large would continue to have
the same service of broadband water but
we pay for whether we were members or
not and I think there's certainly a case
for someone who perhaps wouldn't or
would have a different and cheaper
package I think that's an argument for
paying it but I mean I have to admit if
when I stop being a council of my
Broadband situation won't change well
one thing I wanted to say about the
special allowances and the extra
responsibilities and I have to say
particularly the leader and I've worked
with two of them now as their deputies
if you take away that level of allowance
then many authorities have more you're
actually restricting the position to
people who can afford to do it because
um
it's very difficult to work at the same
time as do particularly that job and I
know in the past
um I've had to like counselor Bell not
not now but I've had to give up work in
order to be a counselor and spend time
doing it
um it's not always easy some people
could juggle their Diaries and it
doesn't affect their income other people
not so much and I don't think we should
rule anyone out obviously anyone who
feels they can hand it back not take it
absolutely fine and good for them nobody
has to take any of it thank you
councilor Bassinger
it's Kevin um I struggled with the
withdrawal of the Broadband I mean I for
one I live out in the sticks as everyone
says and my Broadband used to be on my
phone actually and it used to work
perfectly well when we went to using
teams I not only had to change and buy a
BT Broadband package which is now a
monthly payment but also I had to buy an
Apple Mac because computer I was using
couldn't handle the team speed so you
know I I do I think just to participate
as a counselor I had to buy all this
equipment and I think there are other
counselors probably in the same boat who
probably like me would rather not spent
my money actually buying that kind of
broadband but you know I accept that I
had to just to participate so I I think
the broadband
is actually the Broadband payment I
think is is relevant and I think we
should keep it thank you
oh
nobody else wants to speak uh leader
um uh sum up before we take a vote on
the amendment uh thank you chairman I've
listened all to the the comments made in
the chairman I won't cover every all of
them but um I have sympathies with many
of those of you stated
what I would say is um I know councilor
fluka has made reference to
um driving in the car a lot but I can
assure him that you are even more
accessible when you have a computer and
you can join any meeting by teams I
would like to say since I've been
leading I've been leader previously I
can see the change in demand and the
work that is required of the current
chairpersons I know how hard Council
stamp councilor white and I would say
the leader of the opposition having been
a leader of opposition here I recognize
the time that needs to be applied to all
those positions and the deputy leader
I do think there's been an independent
panel review and therefore
I have to ask myself what is the point
of having them if we don't pay due
regard perhaps what their
recommendations bring forward having um
looked at it I do agree with Mrs
Thompson's amendment I actually do feel
it would be good to have the independent
panel review sit and actually look at
the special responsibility allowances
because I can tell you there is a post
that I consider perhaps should have an
allowance and has not at the moment but
that is a matter for the independent
review panel if we do call them in and I
can see another area where I think
there's an anomaly I'm not going to go
into my responses to the survey where in
fact I think an allowance another
allowance maybe have to be higher there
are responsibilities that go with this
and councilor siddle's quite correct
when you do go out to some of these
outside bodies like some of them are
called for portfolio holders that makes
no difference between whether you're a
Cabinet member or a committee chairman
there is one I used to attend and I
believe councilor siddle then went to it
as well and I think councilor white
should be going to that particular
outside body now and I do agree very
much that actually should the council
agree to the role recommendations before
it tonight it's up to every individual
I'm not going to judge every
individual's personal circumstances here
and I'm not going to comment on them but
what I do comment on is diversity the
local government Association are very
keen to see diverse councils that
represent actually the communities they
serve and that covers anything that
everything disabilities ethnic
minorities more women of a younger age
the whole gamut that be can be
considered inequality this Council also
recently looked at equality diversity
inclusion and perhaps these allowances
in the form that's coming before members
tonight actually do support that and the
independent panel made uh great players
I mentioned when I I introduced this
item about diversity and the reasons for
the Broadband alerts with the increased
proposed the broadback that would cover
I think the removal of the ball band
allowance and I think if you don't want
to have the allowance if you don't have
any use special responsibility
allowances and night councilor stamp
said and councilor Durham and others
that is you have the right to actually
say you don't I certainly in a previous
position did actually work during the
times of austerity Came Upon This
Council and our residents actually took
a reduction in allowance and I did also
on another body that I was a member at
that was my choice I did it privately
and therefore other members have that
right to do so so their chairman at the
beginning of this debate I did move the
recommendations as per the order paper
I'm happy to accept the amendment and
you've agreed that's to be taken as one
on this and I think that's a fair
amendment to be made and I think we do
want to have the independent review
panel look at special responsibility
allowances so with that Amendment
chairman and the other one's little one
to little four inclusive I will move
that recommendation again chairman as I
did in the first place at the start of
this debate thank you Miss Byrd
um
oh God yeah oh sorry yes
um
actually we have recorded for recording
vote Please Mr chairman right
um
I'm just looking at recommendation one
and if you read recommendation one
um and maybe I don't understand why it
doesn't actually say in recommendation
one but if you read recommendation one
in relation to paragraph 3.6 in my mind
we are voting to increase the members
allowance by 5.25 percent
uh Mr Leslie is that correct
that's what he says yep so that's the
average increase
um so that is correct the average
increase is
5.25. that seems to be a good point
because I think there's a recommendation
further on uh uh this white isn't there
uh that all allowances be reduced by
five percent
um so I I take your point
um but I'm going to go to the vote now
chairman we will hold tie ourselves when
we get to the next meeting because we
can't change that
um
uh
uh Miss bird
um our chairman with the remove of the
Broadband it's not exactly 5.2 percent
uh um
councilor siddle
uh yes it but it seems to be uh the will
of the council that little two is is is
not with the Broadband allowance is not
withdrawn so I think what we need to do
is is change is to remove that
particular recommendation
recommendation
um
uh I intend to take the vote on the uh
Amendment
which only relates to that part of the
of the report
uh the uh sorry little three uh little
three
um the I will then take a vote on a
substantive dungeon which will be
um for the report has been presented
uh I'm not sure what to do what we're
doing with the um uh the um
Wi-Fi Broadband allowance at the moment
umation panel look at special
responsibility responsibilities and
that's what you needed as a vote on the
amendment yeah right the amount uh those
in favor of the amendment
um
which
sorry
um misspoken it
can it be put up on the screen
yeah my
um Jim my understanding is and the
deputy leader will correct me if I'm
wrong is that her amendment was that uh
the matter should be a referral to the
remuneration panel only again to review
the special responsibilities allowances
and particularly there was one post
yeah that's what I understand the
amendment is Chairman yeah and that we
okay I'm I'm happy to go with that as
the amendment
uh so those in favor of the amendment
please show uh oh no sorry we do want to
recorded vote
leader uh
sorry you've got the deputy leader sorry
chairman um I actually had two people
speak against the ball about
announcements and and there is in in all
this a facility for applying to get it
back for individuals so I don't quite
understand why we're building the
Broadband allowance
can I just be clear the amendment I took
to be counselor Thompson and I think I
did move the entirety of the report with
that amendment in yes and that was
seconded I thought german yes it was and
that and that is the the subject to the
amendment will become
uh the substantive motion
we have just got
the amendment which refers to the
special responsibility allowance being
referred to the remuneration panel
I just quit that is what we take now
Council schemes I just simply want to
say that I'm very now I'm very confused
on councilor siddle's proposal that we
uh remove the requirement for Broadband
though let's say we remove the removal
of broadband well we need that to be if
we vote on the first thing how do we get
an opportunity to development because
you can make another amendment to us why
don't we just include it now is my
question uh because it's not been
debated
it has been debated with respect
chairman it's been debated and mentioned
by four or five people not not as an
amendment it hasn't
that's true we have to we have to be
formal with these things
um right uh Miss bird would you call a
role then please
yes that's it
um
please when I call your name uh abstain
thank you Council Bell
abstain
abstain
China
four
abstain
before
oops
that's the head four
that's the hell
against
far
four
keys
four
against
four
full
it counts for sure to see four
by four
that's the schemes abstain
abstain
against
that's for Stevens
four
councilman abstain
four
that's Mrs Thompson
thoughts
Council Miss White
four
I keep checking the results about our 74
3 against and seven this day thank you
uh that amendment is carried therefore
the substantive motion is the report as
it stands as amended by referral Bank
um for the special responsibility
allowance it's the remuneration panel
councilor siddle
uh thank you Gemma so I would like to
put forward a recommendation that uh the
Broadband allowance payment is not
withdrawn uh from April 2023.
thank you
um
is that a great Council Fluker what
channel
you know this is really difficult
because
um I only get a
megapixels a second is it tiny is it MPS
MPS I only get eight uh and that's my
service level which means if if my
wife's uh ordering my Christmas present
I can't turn on my laptop
and go to civica but of course I could
enhance that but it would cost more than
30 quid a month so I do Wonder we're not
is that a special needs is it can I
apply for it uh I don't know and uh and
and just to pick up on what councilor
Channel said it would be nice to get
some nice young men on here other than
uh young women thank you I thought that
was nice
um
so we do you agree that Amendment
members great
no
um all right my vote can be called
against that channel okay
um yes let's have a show of hands those
in favor of that Amendment please show
somebody got a score yet
against
two no sorry oh four sorry
um
uh I think that amendment's carried uh
now I'll put the substantive motion
which I hope everybody understands
the the
um
Broadband stays
and the uh special responsibility
allowance is referred to the
remuneration panel all that all the rest
of the report as is is that agreed call
it vote please hello
um councilor
um Miss Byrd please
for clarity this is to increase the
members allowance by 5.25 isn't it if
you say so councilor fluke
I I I don't know
um
I think Mr Leslie has confirmed that so
we're now going to vote to put up the
members allowance by 5.25 okay thank you
I think that was a substance of the
report yeah
yeah that was the substance of the
report members uh Miss bird would you
call a roll please
yes I remember if you can indicate for
against which state please when I call
your name this is for the substantive
motion as the term is just set up I
started through cancer treatment four
thank you Council bill for
four
sorry
counselor Boyce abstain
council Mrs Tanner
for
thank you Council jurik
abstain
for
eign
abstain
[Music]
against
four
against
four
that's the whole
councilor keys
against
him
for
that's the shortest thing four
four
against
dispensary abstain
Council system
against because of the increase
for
against
The Strain against
him
four
okay
um
are fifteen four seven against four
extensions thank you that motion is
carried thank you we now move on to
um agenda item 13 member training
criteria Pages 73 to 76 leader sorry
could we wait for councilor white please
because some of us do understand why
she's she's left can we wait for her
well can we see if she's all right
chairman I think oh she's coming back
laughs
foreign
agenda item 13 member training criteria
Pages 73 to 76 uh leader
oh sorry Jim I got I caught myself sorry
oh dear I thought it was going to get
winded then all right chairman yes uh
this is the member training criteria
report
and obviously it's regarding member
training um and a member may members may
recall an early report came to this
Council and then was deferred for the
members of the working members training
working group to meet and consider the
report as indicated proposes criteria to
manage individual member training
approaches and processes for managing
and uh through the program performance
and governance manager in consultation
with the main member training working
group there's been a budget applied for
member training which is 2800 and the
report refers to recommendations of a
previous internal audit report about
formalizing a training plan
um certain areas are highlighted as
mandatory in paragraph 3.3 regarding
that training and the training those
training courses that have to be
delivered to members and they should in
in parking also it refers to promotion
of LGA sessions and also there are ad
hoc training courses appendix hm is
there to cover the aspects of ad hoc
member approaches to attend a training
course and how that should be actioned
and in consultation initially with group
leaders chairman of committees SNR PG a
and subject to appendix a chairman being
approved under the recommendations a
member form will be created remember the
training working group did meet you and
it has actually met on two occasions but
I'm making reference now to the meeting
of the 18th of November and that
requested approach Redhawk training
request be included in consultation with
the member training and development
working group and the approach is set
out so that all members have equal
access and understand how to make
training requests chairman I therefore
refer to the recommendations in the
members pack and on the order paper
little one that members approved the
criteria set at appendix a as a process
when addressing individual training
queries and two that the program's
performance and governance manager is
authorized to establish an annual
training program of members in
accordance with the approved criteria in
consultation with the member training
working group and I think Mr Paul
Johnson may want to say that's something
that might be his report
Mr Dodson
um I have nothing to add thanks Jim
thank you members
councilor Stan yeah
yeah um yes thank you chairman
um I actually think that 2800 is quite
measly for a council this size um
Burnham Town Council do over 3 000 for
councilors to be trained I think next
year we all know because we can see the
amount of electioneering going on is uh
in May and you're going to I would hope
would get quite a little a new cohort of
new members more diverse to include
everybody that we represent and and I
know in the past that's been covered at
the member training working group that
um the budget has been quite
substantially more in previous years so
is there any allowance or any
possibility that if that more money was
needed chairman it could be allocated
because we all know well-trained
councilors can lead to actually better
well-trained Council to represent their
members chairman councilor stem you make
a very good point about
um there will be a lot of new members
next year uh whatever else happens uh so
I think you make a good point um Mr
Leslie would you like to comment on that
yeah we can add some to that I think we
also have um subscriptions uh through
the LGA who offer um certain courses for
free we also have um the treasury
management
um which is part of our built-in
um
budget with uh advisors as well which is
outside of that training budget and of
course if the group went through
identified the training need and there
was insufficient budget to cover that
then of course a request could come
forward once that figure is known for
additional funding Council fluka
right okay thank you chairman
um yeah I I sort of concur with what
counts the stamp says I've got a feeling
in the training budget at
um at South Paris she's actually in
excess of 3 000 pounds and we get free
training as well offered to us by eal
see some some extraordinary good courses
German courses planning courses all
sorts of stuff but Gemma my proposal was
that we increased this budget and try
and move it as close to 20 000 pounds as
possible per annum
um and that proposal was was based
really chairman on that's not agreeing
the last recommendations because the
councils just spent 12 and a half
thousand pounds on increasing its
members
um its members allowances
um you'll that you'll find that figure
buried in the report somewhere but it's
twelve and a half thousand so you know I
I would propose that we we double this
determine this as an amendment
um to the the recommendation so that
would be Roman 3. German that we
actually increase the members training
budget and I think also whilst we're
we're sort of um talking about training
um I think it's really important that
rather than wait for the election to be
called and rather than wait for people
to come forward we sort out some dates
for where we're going to have the
planning training because I I always
remember my good friend councilor Jarvis
Mr Jarvis now he's retired
um and he missed out on his training
because of serious work commitments and
his argument always was he only ever got
two weeks notice I mean he did it in the
end but I just think we just should be
just a little bit more upfront with
what's required as early as possible
your amendment is that it be increased
to five thousand yes 500 is it or yeah
if you want to um I thought you said
doubled I thought you said I just it
just looks terribly measly if anybody to
quote yes let's get down to some hard
facts what would your Amendment say
double I don't think 200 pounds
what Sam are you proposing
remember
and I assume the Council of stamp will
second that
yes I will second it because I'm a great
believer in training
um
I think I've got counselor
Stevens next
thank you chair first of all I just want
to ask abandon please oh sorry
first of all I just want to ask a very
basic question in the member training
criteria where it says how much is the
course
um the first one is it's in a budget of
90 pounds the second one says under 90
pounds but the overall put is limited
and I think that's just a mistake and
I'd like to know what it meant to say
please I think it means 2 800. oh
I think it should say pot but it's a
minor detail it's just a typo
um I'd also like to make the point that
I was on the licensing committee for
almost a year before I had training I
didn't know that you were supposed to
have training it makes total sense that
you are but I didn't know it and so I
also didn't know that there were
licensing meetings taking place people
have heard me say this before that I
simply wasn't invited to so I didn't
know
so I was missing out on being able to
sit on the licensing committee or on the
training and that was at a time when I
could have done training anywhere
because they were online so I didn't
even need to wait for something to be
local and the reason I was given was
that oh well it's very expensive don't
you know to go on touch training and we
need to be very very clear we've got a
lot of new members we've just said
there's a lot of new members coming in
next year so rather than just picking a
random number out of the air oh let's
have five thousand let's have three
thousand I think we should be counting
up how many new members are we likely to
have on each of the Committees where
you've got to have training and at least
calculate the costs of that as a base
before we add in any other nice to have
training and I'd like to see those
figures please thank you
um
package thank you chairman I'd just like
to concur with cancer stamp and Council
fluka first of all that
training is very important and we're
going to have new members next year in
particularly new members who might be on
planning committees we're planning
training is compulsory so we have to
have
a larger I would say nearer 10 000
rather than six thousand even though we
don't use it but bear in mind all the
training we have to do especially on
planning
um we should increase it thank you
um Mr Dodson wants to make some comments
I think
so you're ready yes thank you chairman
it was it was in answer to a couple of
the point points that a couple of
members have made
um one of them regarding the the
training being scheduled for new members
and the onboarding process that's
already being put in place in a schedule
that it's intended to circulate uh all
candidates when they register to be a
member of the the councilman to stand
for election to ensure exactly those
points are addressed
um and just just briefly on the um the
licensing training it wasn't a matter of
the cost of it it was a matter of
availability and that training can
sometimes be be difficult to arrange so
it's just a point of clarity
um from feedback I've had from staff
thank you Jim councilor Darren
foreign
trainee is probably one of the most
important things because having
well-trained counselors is absolutely
essential if we're going to make the
right decisions and scarily I find
myself agreeing with councilor stamp and
indeed councilor Fluker
um but particularly as we've heard in
the areas where we are making
uh decisions based on law that is
planning and that is licensing which
have nothing to do with the political
aspect and we're not representing our
Wards we are making
we are making sorry trim that's yeah
we're making decisions based on uh
legislative uh
um items so absolutely and i would
support um as much as we can afford
unless it's been said whether we ended
up spending it but absolutely we we must
have ignoring the fact that there are
new members coming and ignoring the fact
that we get free training from ealc and
the LGA we should have a good sufficient
budget in-house for providing the
training that is necessary to enable
members to do their jobs properly thank
you Council
uh thank you chairman I was going to say
a lot of what Mr Dodson said in terms of
uh the onboarding that the new members
will get this time which was very very
different to what I went through when I
when I was elected to this Council uh
and that's where the member training
working group has been invaluable in
terms of defining and creating uh
training needs analysis and and forming
a more detail plan and the other thing
that uh who needs commending is Mrs
Hughes who has put an awful lot of work
uh into the training plan into this new
induction and you know all new
candidates will get a pack even yeah as
soon as they put their name forward so
that will be invaluable to anybody who's
thinking you're standing at the election
and it will have all the dates of things
like planning training so they can make
sure they put them in their diary
councilor Spencer
thank you chair
um well I have to say
um that so far my experience of the
training and I'm not getting anyone so
everyone tries but as an experienced
trainer it really isn't training
um and um and I just think this Psalm is
seems quite ludicrous actually and I
don't really understand why we haven't
got more detail in this report about
what the more work up of what the need
might be so that we know what we're
voting for because this all seems a bit
loose and if there is a lovely plan and
I'm sure there must be but wouldn't it
be nice to have some of the detail
because I can't see any of that here so
my feedback on this is that that figure
is completely ludicrous as a trainer it
just is ludicrous and I think that going
forward I'm sure the working group is
member training working group is doing
fantastically well but I'd like to hear
some more about it thank you Council
wife
um thank you Mr chilling if you might
indulge me that I can stay sitting
because I can't it's not easy for me
um I have to say unusually I agree with
councilor stamp and councilor Fluker on
this one
um and I think member training is
invaluable I mean I I undertake a lot of
training um outside of Malden District
Council particularly on matters like
planning and I also think that in
relation to a gender item 14 that this
is where this extra training is
absolutely required and it for me it's
not just for new members it's for all
members and I I think it's vital that we
do take it forward and I support the
recommendation
um I think councilor stand before I come
back to the leader councilor Stan
thank you chairman all I was going to
say from what Mr Dodson said was about
the onboarding process surely they must
have um and that I'll also congratulate
how much work's been done but they must
have a figure so so if they must know
what training has to be done that's
mandatory in an approximate cost so
rather than put cancer fluka and
everybody else on the spot to say get a
figure out the the sky maybe we just
maybe need to defer it and say we'll
wait till the next meeting with some
accurate information uh oh thank you
um I I I wasn't trying to put Council
Fluker on the spot but I thought when he
um introduced the item he said it ought
to be double and that was all I I just
wanted a figure to be to be stated
German I wasn't sticking up for him I
was making a point
laughs
yeah
um I'll I'll wind up the debate with me
coming back to the leader
uh thank you chairman uh oh my God he's
just gone down again nevermind uh
chairman the point I've made actually
um councilor siddle has made good points
and he's obviously reiterating what Mr
Dodson said and counselor stamp
obviously has made some good points but
actually both those members do sit on
the member training group councilor
stamp was present and
um councilor siddle and in fact at that
training group at the last meeting we
did have figures coming forward
regarding the training over previous
years and uh certainly uh Cheryl Hughes
Mrs Hughes did actually circulate
figures going back to 2018. well yes it
was higher than actually now of the 201
800 was over five thousand and I asked
for further detail on that and then
subsequently it dwindled now I think the
way to deal with this chairman there is
as I moved earlier the recommendations
of little one and nickel two and nickel
two says that the program's performance
and governance manager is authorized to
establish an annual training program of
members in accordance with the approved
criteria and in consultation with the
member training working group and I
think that that training group I'm sure
Council siddle will be wanting further
meetings that can look at the training
and there can be through that perhaps a
real assessment of perhaps what a
training budget could be bearing in mind
what may come out of further discussions
with that training group and certainly
report back to council I think that
would be the way rather than measured
figures because at first I heard Council
of food could say 20 000 then he
moderated that a bit with five thousand
and that certainly ties up with
something in the past but I think the
member training group is the one ably
that's been um coming to the equation
um bearing in mind the deferment of that
report from September and now we're
moving forward that body is the one
including councilor white sonnet
um councilor Helm has a right to be on
that training group as well I think
that's the body where all these matters
be considered chairman in an appropriate
way and I'm sure I'm hoping councilor
siddle might see that as the way forward
I think the problem leader is that Mr
Leslie needs this information to
actually produce a budget
and you seem to be suggesting that this
figure
arrive at a later date Mr Leslie when's
the latest time that you can you would
need this figure
I think chairman um
the figure is unlikely to be
significantly material for the budget
setting process I usually we'll look to
building final figures ready for the
starting resources committee on the I
think the 26th of January this time
however we of course have supplementary
estimates throughout the year so it can
be outside of the budget budgeting Mr
Leslie it's not ideal budgeting chairman
but I think due to the figures we're
talking about it wouldn't be a
significant impact coming forward so it
can be done outside the normal budget
cycle
um
are you happy to withdraw your Amendment
no
um I mean the whole purpose of this is
we just seemed everything just seems to
be going on the merry-go man but old Mr
Leslie's trying to do his budget
um you know if we if we increase this to
to ten thousand or Twenty or thirty
thousand pounds
it's got to be justified the expected
but what we don't what I don't want is
you know Mr Leslie coming back with all
the other problems he's going to face
next year coming back to to ask a
supplementary uh estimate to increase
this whereas if we cut if we cut this
budget now make it a sensible level he
doesn't have to do that we've got this
working group in the background that
deals with training you know and and my
my I must think of another word on the
hog type but why why do we keep hold
time obviously we used to say because
you've got a budget you don't have to
spend it well we're not going to lose it
but look counselor channel is absolutely
right you know in the past we had a
massive but a member budget but because
members have been here so long some felt
that they knew everything and others
felt they didn't need training uh I can
see Mr quilts almost smiling without my
glasses off I'll uh no he's grimacing
um but you know and they were different
times you know and I I really do
sympathize with members that have joined
this Council during the municipal period
and perhaps those that joined in 2019
because I do feel as though the training
was lacking in some ways so Jim you know
the reason why I'm putting this this
amendment forward is in good faith
um it allows you know it allows us to
sort out some proper training and it
gives the officers you know Mr Leslie
can put the figure in this budget and
then hopefully hopefully report back in
12 months time that there was an under
spend of 2 200 pounds but I think we
should do what we can to help him and he
should be helpful so so are you prepared
to withdraw your Amendment and and and
have a firm figure put to SNR in on the
27th and I I I'm quite happy to propose
now that we we make the budget 200 pound
per member 6 200 pounds we don't have to
spend it and Mr Leslie doesn't have to
come back yeah thank you
um councilor councilor schemes very
quickly please yeah thank you chairman
um I'm just to Lost like I know one or
two other members are but how we can
have such a
guesstimate as a training figure I mean
whatever counselors are going to require
in the way of training I don't know I'm
planning is obviously one licensing is
another but they must all have fixed
costs
to do the training of all councilors as
in planning or certain counselors as in
licensing surely it's not Beyond
the writ of man to go away work out what
needs doing have a cost against that
they must all be available the costs
against these training items
and then come back with that and say
what is actually going to cost one
thousand ten thousand twenty five I
don't know what it's going to cost but
this is so Airy fairy I'm not willing to
vote on it thank you Council skeins
yes I just want to support what uh
Council juk said and councilor
spencerley and others we need more
training we need much better training
than we're getting we need a bigger
budget thank you uh right we seem to be
reopening the debate Council of Fleming
councilor Swain thank you Chad and
before I made a decision
um could we perhaps the uh figures for
the staff training budget could be
shared with members I think that would
be quite interesting thank you
I don't I don't know whether we can find
those figures at the moment I'll I'll
listen to councilor Swain first
thank you chairman well my point is that
we are supposed to be we're asked to
vote on a couple of recommendations
which don't say anything about money
um the figure of two thousand eight
hundreds is merely a bit of background
information so we can passage to
recommendations and we then await to
here
um the uh what a the
um training program would amount to as a
separate idea except a separate report
to whoever
um pgna probably thank you uh this is
Fleming we don't have that information
available at the moment
actually
um councilor Thompson
um thank you thank you chairman I hope
I've got confused and I'm not repeating
anything anyone else's says but I don't
quite see why we can't have the member
training working group meet as soon as
possible so we actually have a figure we
can take to us enough because the wrong
well I don't know why we need to guess a
figure now we've got a we've got an
amendment of 6200 which I'll now uh take
the vote on
um those in
nothing on the agenda about voting for a
budget on this
well
um
yeah yeah
um I think um my advice is that we can
take this amendment
so those in favor of the amendment of
the training budget for members being
6200 which is truly seconded I think by
councilor stamp
foreign
against
[Music]
four
that was four Miss Bird yeah
um abstain
thank you Mrs Chava
get it over and done with four
the reasons I just gave abstain
for
Edwards four
Council freaker
this is for my emotions
foreign
four
cancel or that's the keys four
four
see four
abstain
S four four
abstain
three four
abstain
abstain
I can't wait for
and show me the results that are 24 100
against and six extensions uh thank you
uh that amendment is carried now does
the the
um substantive uh motion to council is
the as the recommendation as in little
one and in little two
um I think after the approved criteria
and budget of 6200
uh be inserted and that becomes the
substantive motion all those in favor
great thank you uh right members we go
on to a gender item 14
um would members like a break
um shall we say five past nine
adjourned until five past nine
we we
adjourn to
e
did you get that this bird
right let's let's get down and have a
members uh we're we're live again and we
turn to a gender item 14 area planning
committee review on pages 77 to 8 88
leader
[Music]
now can I just move straight to Mr
Dodson then leader
um
okay I'll leave my computer off chairman
um Aero planning committee's chairman uh
this is to review as you said the
planning committee reviews and confirm
whether future approach will include
error planning committees or a single
committee uh the report please perform
uh members consider two aspects
objectives sound decision making and
resource implications maintaining
current ways of working
are three in total of the whole district
and every member or member can sit on
one
um what I would say is Chairman
um all members have planning training to
sit on a planning committee or should do
it we've decided that that should be
mandatory so applies to all members and
the report highlights the take-up of by
members
um it gives the percentages there's a
legal requirement that all members have
read the papers uh 3.4 refers to the
pass report and details how it can
provide a employee pass and how it can
provide high quality help and advice and
back in 2021 pass conducted a review of
planning committees how the work both
practically and with good decision
making could be looked at as a result of
this a wider number of recommendations
emerge in respect of our general
operations and working practices I refer
members to para 3.5 which highlight the
corporate governance audit by internal
auditors in July 2022 and that report
did actually go to the planning sorry
the performance governance and audit
Committee in July 2022 hence uh the
reason why uh we're having this tonight
as well chairman I've drawn members
attention to 3.6 which refers to the
council's budget and deficit and a
business case about how we run
committees 3.7 refers to findings and
regarding the issues of 25 hours of
Office of time resources needed to
sustainably manage Arrangements going
forward
3.8 detail of the level of governance
and the past reports highlighted risks
which are detailed in in the report
chairman and also one of those things
was regarding a legal officer perhaps
should be present in a single area a
single committee would allow that and I
highlight also that the opening scrutiny
committee has a work plan item around
planning decision process and there's an
overview excuse me interim report
um of October including similar findings
in respect of member training and
capacity that a small Core Group
involved in planning would address
there's recommendations chairman run to
little three on the order paper that run
Council reviews the table in 3.8 and
notes concerns two Council updates the
committee structure and removes error
planning committees are replaced with
nine-seated planning committee from May
2023 and that's adopting appendix a and
then nickel 3 should Council agree to
detailed implementation plan with clear
updated member calling process and
expectations be brought
forward and Back to the Future Council I
don't know if I read my reading writing
right at the end one there gem that's
the best I can do and I'll try and get
into my computer now thank you
Mr Dodson
thank you chairman
this paper was prompted following
internal audit of governance that found
the planning advisory service report had
not been properly considered at Council
and this report brings back the main
issues of area planning committees
whilst that was the prompt the case for
change in our approach to planning
committees has become even more
compelling over the last 12 months to
the extent that the evidence for changes
in the in the the view of the corporate
leadership team overwhelming and as a
corporate leadership team we would
recommend this change
um in the strongest of terms
why is the case for change so compelling
broadly National guidance and best
practice has moved away from area
planning with members encouraged to
think of the whole district and policy
we're making planning decisions rather
than acting as Ward members
Additionally the review of development
Management Service that has taken place
has a key finding that the area planning
model is contributing to inefficiency
and resource pressure in the service at
a time when it's difficult to recruit
and retain staff
to manage planning processes to the
extent that the situation is dire and
must be rectified through a number of
measures
including a single planning committee
there are a number of governance and
operational concerns surrounding our
current area planning committee model
and these are given in high level at
section 3.8 of the report including the
budget saving we would be able to make
if our model changes
overall the report recommends replacing
area planning with a nine-seat planning
committee as per the terms of reference
set out in appendix a
this would still retain District
planning for matters currently referred
there
I would like to clarify that within the
table at 3.8 of the report
no final report and conclusions have
been brought forward from the ons
planning decision making item yet so we
can't say whether this would have
supported area planning or or a single
committee
to help members to further understand
the case for change we've invited
Stephen Barker from the planning
advisory service the key advisory body
for planning Services across the country
to provide some further information as
an independent expert
through you chairman I'd like to invite
Stephen to speak and to ask the question
um to Stephen um could you please
explain that the benefits of a single
planning committee for Malden District
Council and why it would be such a
benefit to members officers and
residents
thank you chairman um please Mr Parker
thank you very much
thank you Council as well and as you
probably know from the receiving the
report that was done back in 2021. uh
probably the most difficult Association
so we do a number of these reviews
across the country I think but we do
about 30 and a quick look at how many
we've done in a year we've looked at the
30 planning committees in the last in
the last year we've delivered around 50
lots of training to councils and I've
done about 50 sessions with committee
chairs as well so just on the back of
that you can see how many planet
expenses I've had to look at in the in
in the wealth of time that we've been
been looking at them so
um every time we look at a panic
committee we look at degree under like
five basic principles so that's around
is the process that decision making
clear for the public uh is it making the
best opportunity to be accessible to the
public
um is the council making the best usage
resources in making decisions and
committee is he presenting a confident
and professional approach to decision
making by the council is it making good
their decisions so there are sorts of
Facebook if you like for what we look
through when we go through
um one of the things that I've tried to
do here is just I put a table together
with some comparable authorities so
we've used some of the uh sit for
nearest neighbors of Pharmacists which I
believe has been circulated in their
packs is that your information sheets
so as you can kind of see from here so
just a raft of authorities who are of a
similar well who said today David's
neighbors are of a stimulus size as you
like or similar similarities anyway
and I've kind of see if you can see
things such as molding
approach the house such a dignity is to
the norm I would say and it's just an
opportunity just to sort of highlight
this thing at my work generally across
in the teams were within pairs I would
think there's probably less than five
percent of local authorities
and overcoming authorities who are
willing area committees now most of
those who've got an area committee do it
for a reason now most of that reason is
because the decisive to geography or
even the volume of planning applications
that they're seeing
now the reason that we made the
recommendation in the report when we
came to see the the orthodical came to
see the Committees was
molten's volume of applications in
geographical size probably doesn't lend
itself to even with those arguments okay
and so
there is a real you know the the
resources will be able to cover
um uh area committees for a local
Authority is larger but also the the
volume of
um work that is also taken to to Aid
councilors in doing their role on
committees is large as well so you can
start to see it's sort of using it from
both sides and the resources both the
council and also the resourcing the time
in the councils as well
we mainly recognize that there are a lot
lots of different ways to run a brand
committee and there are a lot of
varieties you like across the country so
I say the fact that area communities I
use those sparingly I think he's such an
indicative in itself
um one of the things that we did say we
made a recommendation of the nine I
think committee members in the report
um as you can kind of see from the
comparable uh local authorities if you
like within the table and we recommended
nine now we say submitting about 11 and
9 and it's kind of through an
alternatively to sort of work to how how
best that fits and you can see through
the table that quite a few are a bit
higher than that that's often for a few
reasons sometimes that's about them
making sure that the Democratic
representation of parties uh is is
allowed
um within the committee so you know but
principally we came to our number
between 11 and 9 we did a big survey
with a number of accounts and officers
across the country who look at who work
on planning committee and that was what
their recommendation was what a good
number of of committee members was for a
committee saying that's kind of where we
came with the nine figure and we could
have aided on the nine thing
you liked whether he has a bit of
recommendation
because of the size of the council if
you like uh you know 31 members uh in in
the council within that that was a sort
of a that end of it if you like compared
to say that that Litchfield for example
we're on there for like 53 uh members of
the Roman Council so
that's sort of where that nine ticket
came from
us
um
you could have asked me just to sort of
say
um so what are the benefits really yes I
mean I suppose you're looking to find
members offices and residents so and
intensively the benefits he remembers is
actually being my planning Community is
actually quite a bit challenged in
undertaking involved if you have as
award counselor as an advocate for for
your area so
because of the challenges around
pre-determination for sitting on fire
Infinity it actually is having a smaller
number of members on the committee means
that members can reward members can take
their role to represent the community at
the count after committee so they can
actually front for them that in the
committee as they as they forget quite a
complex thing you know most people look
if they're on look you don't don't do
very many committees in their lifetime
you walk into an in such a judicial
process if you like it's actually quite
daunting so having that broadcast a lot
of fun becomes quite a strong advocacy
role and kind of a key role to take so
not only does it allow sort of you know
the counselors to do their job as
advocates if you like well the decision
makers which I'm making decisions not
just for the war but for the wider
Council and even as a ward councilor
sitting on a committee they've still got
enrolled to take that wider Viewpoint if
you like also if you could check Money
Changes quite a lot so being kept up to
date and being kept what informed
it's great to see that you were talking
earlier about mandatory training
committee members Our advice is
committee members should be trained
annually at least on a mandatory level
because the planning process changes so
much both within the policies that the
council has but also nationally as well
so
availability team
I love a number of counselors updated
and trained because you know quite a key
element if you like to be able to to
smooth things forward so also try to
keep consistency between committees as
well is a big challenge because there
has to be consistency rate you made
across the council because you've got
area committees there's a much bigger
role for the chairs of the Committees to
be able to keep consistency across in
the officers to work as well within that
so it you know it it just that you can
see where the increasing the time and
resourcing falls into it benefits to
officers you've asked for as well so
obviously as we've talked about this
we've reducing the requirements
regarding the administration of multiple
committees but also the cost of like
producing necessary committee papers is
going with that also the cost of office
of time to be able to support the
committee so actually making sure that
the officers are available to be able to
talk to community members of our cases
and and also just to be able to bring
that work that actually does that has
been a consistency across protein
approaches as well between Infinities as
well
and also you mentioned residence and
that yeah having that water counts that
are there is an ability to advocate for
as I mentioned it's a sort of a key role
I think within this and it also allows
Ward councilors to have to to actually
sort of campaign for as well where they
can't do that when they're on the bank
committee because they've got to be able
to show that they're not only
predetermined you when they sit there so
um
that load I think is actually such a key
role as well but it almost feels like
it's just it it it's a shame to lose
that and actually by having the smaller
number of accountances on a committee on
a single Council then that Advocate law
becomes larger with much more apparent
for the community as well
um there is a lot of challenge sometimes
about moving from an alien Committee
just to say to go to a a sort of a
smaller number and a single Council
regarding the you know the the a world
of democracy is lost I suppose within
this you have to remember that crime
committee is not a democratic process
it's actually uh it's essentially a
regulatory function the Democracy in it
is coming by the fact that there are
counselors who are elected from the
council who sits onto the committee and
the fact that actually you know I'd say
95 of councils are winning one committee
kind of has a slight argument in it
it's still working if you like and the
democracy is still in in India as a part
to playing it by the fact that these
divided Council was making the decision
and
something else I just wanted to note as
well I was having a little when I was
having a look at when the council asked
me to come and just present it had a
little look at what your appeals or
performances and there's another slide
here if you could just move on division
I've highlighted this is
this is something that we see quite a
lot from uh councils who have got
multiple committees and but their their
appeals losses are actually quite High
some of that's to do with the fact that
it's hard to get it's hard for
consistent decision making to happen
the reason I highlight this is there is
a cut-off Mark of 10 so if you lose more
than 10 of your major applications on
appeal then there's not then there's an
option for government to take away
decision making planning powers from the
local Authority so at the moment the
council is running about you know 7.7
and now on my my work my mastered this
if you were to you know carry on in the
rate you the way you were I think you'll
probably just be underneath a 10 Mark
where it actually if you lost another
one on appeal uh you're going to be over
that and so the government potentially
could be looking to put intervention on
the account on the council the reason I
mentioned this is because there's
consistency about decision making I
haven't looked at the
should be able to be aware of
then you know that as some of this comes
to this idea of how well admitting
particularly
uh could you tell me about the next
slide please
yeah
there's a couple of things
in the LGA but kind of try and help the
castle so yeah our accommendation as was
made back in in 2021 was to move from a
multiple area
because you do want to go down
what I suggest we do is
he on your action Advisory Group if you
want to help aid that all these reports
ahead of planning to sits on that to the
aid and take give advice that he goes
through and we couldn't take the
subsequent review if you do move down to
a single committee to see how he's
working sorry I'm sorry to interrupt you
but could could you um
okay sorry right
I've been told that I'm out of order
carry on please
[Music]
do any Appeals
again we can still change this account
as well we got into community members
and also if we just deteriorate you can
actually get to the point where we can
advise you regarding your descriptions
as a secretary mistake we can do this
effectively and just to say all of that
is
[Music]
is there anybody that wishes to ask a
question
sorry
yes of course yeah chairman I just
um based on on I I just want to focus on
the report at the moment Chan because I
I fear that this might take some time
um and Tim and I I just wanted a point
of clarity over paragraph 3.3
um and in paragraph three point three
which the leader quite rightly
highlighted us about the legal
requirement that all members should have
read and thoroughly reviewed the
paperwork well chairman I I you know I'm
very uncomfortable about that statement
in the report and and I have had uh an
exchange of emails
um with the monitoring officer regarding
Nissan and and he's quite rightly
directed me to R uh r on the application
of Hill versus Cornwall uh County
Council but that actually deals within
adequacies of an officer's report so
obviously members couldn't make an
informed decision
um are these Selby's getting very old
now and it covers quite a lot of things
and I couldn't actually see specifically
where it led on
um where it led on members not being not
not having read the reports but my
biggest concern chairman which
takes this argument and in fact
paragraph 3.3 in a completely different
direction
um I wrote to the monitoring office uh
on the 22nd on the 26th of September
following a district planning committee
meeting
um which dealt with an application in
Malden Road uh wooden Mortimer Essex and
I bought the attention of the monitoring
officer that clearly from what members
said
they had not read the report
and in some instances they were
predetermined
so now we've got now we've got officers
that haven't read the report and members
that haven't read the report
predetermination and I believe
discrimination as well
and all I got back and I'm happy to to
circulate this all I got back from the
monitoring office
was basically saying what you each of
these items meant so there was
absolutely no action taken by the
monitoring officer they didn't even
speak to these these members so this
business about there's a legal
requirement to to read reports we either
enforce this or we don't but based on
the documentary evidence that I've just
referred to we clearly don't
so what I'd like to ask the monitoring
officer is on behalf of his office
going to make sure that we are legally
replying compliant going forward are you
Jessica are you just going to say well
if you don't read the reports you're
subjects you're a judicial review
because I can't find anywhere where
council's been subject to a judicial
review on those terms thank you yeah
um Mr quails uh wishes to say something
um it's axiomatic that
um
Council report should be read by
members the Cornwall case that I sent to
you Council fluka talks about the
importance of the adequacy of reports so
it follows it's self-evident that
members should read it now I'm not quite
sure what council Fluker chairman is
asking wanting me to do is he wanting me
after each planning to committee to
cross-examine each member to see whether
they pass a quiz in relation to each
report it's quite clear that if members
don't read the reports and seek to
understand them then yes there is a
possibility that a judicial review could
be brought but it's not possible for me
there's nothing in the code of conduct
that requires explicitly members to read
officers reports but it's axiomatic that
they should read those reports and I've
given advice to members and I think
members will remember I sent an email
around recently which surely Council
Fluker will remember
um where I said that if counselors
haven't had time to read reports then
they should abstain
from that particular matter and if they
haven't got time they should actually
select which particular matters they
feel they should read and leave the
others so
I think I've already addressed that so
I'm not quite sure what more councilor
fluke would like me to do other than an
interview of members about their
performance and reading reports I think
I think councilor Fluker has made his
point uh no challenge can I just come
back briefly the the debate is on the
whole paper not just on 3.3 but chem 3.3
I mean as a member I feel quite
threatened because it says one thing I I
wrote to the monitoring office
highlighting that members have not
complied with the requirement to read
reports now I would have thought in the
best interest of this Council the
monitoring officer should have listened
to the tape and I actually directed them
I think at the time when they needed to
listen and at the very very least sent
out another reminder but as far as
please we are not debating individual
no I'm just trying to give weight to
this legal decisions unless you as you
said to me Mr quelch and Morrisons I
look forward to seeing you in the
chamber and I always yeah
um councilor Darren I've got your
Council schemes yeah thank you thank you
thank you very much indeed can I can I
just start off by actually supporting
what council of fluke has just said
it's quite clear sitting in some
meetings that there are members that
don't read it and if you go back in time
to when we had the papers sent out to us
in an envelope with an elastic band
around them I recall several meetings
where you could look around the table
the benches and you could see that the
papers were still had the elastic band
and were so neat they quite clearly
hadn't been open so it used to go on and
I'm sure it still does but on this very
subject
members
want to and should be able to represent
their residents at and Parish councils
at planning meetings
but by having a single planning
committee doesn't prevent that at all in
fact it's reinforced
because members that are speaking
strongly and banging the table or doing
whatever they want to do for attention
can do so without the fear of being
accused of predetermination
because they're not voting I will give
you a case in point at the Essex County
Council that has a single planning
committee
that's the player who councilor player
who represents the Riven Hall division
has the Riven Hall incinerator in his
division which clearly from his parish
councils and all his residents are
absolutely opposed to however when it
was put to the planning committee
there was no real valid reason why
permission shouldn't be granted there
wouldn't have been very many valid
planning reasons but he had to support
the wishes of his residents so he was
able to go to that committee and be as
expansive as he wanted
extolling the reasons why this
incinerator shouldn't be given planning
permission
but of course he wasn't put in the
invidious position of having to vote
against against officers recommendations
and vote against something where there
was no reason so members would be able
to stand up and represent their
individual cases in support of their
Parish councils in support of their
residents and be as vocal as they want
and so I said without this sort of
Damocles of an accusation of
predetermination hanging over their head
you've seen
advice from the planning advisory
service the LGA the Auditors that this
is best practice the other matter that
is absolutely relevant when Devolution
comes along and we will probably be part
of the North Essex group of councils and
invest and therefore sharing services
we won't be able to share planning
Services if we've still got area
committees because none of our partner
authorities have area committees so that
it's going to come sooner or later
whether we like it or not and whatever
we say today so chairman I absolutely
support a single planning committee
where the members can be trained they
can be regularly kept up to date with uh
with the legislation and as Mr Barker
has just said we have to be it gives you
the opportunity to be advocates for your
residents as loudly as as they you want
without this issue of predetermination
and
chairman three minutes yeah well okay
chairman I'm quite happy to sit down
because I think I've made my point thank
you
councilor Fleming
[Music]
thank you
um previously I've been dead against
moving to a single committee
I think the thing that's changed it for
me is of current Staffing crisis
um planners committee clerks I mean I am
very concerned about what is going to
happen
um you know after May
the situation is likely to get worse so
you know if you if members don't want to
do this you know they need to to do
something to well I don't know what that
can be but that something needs to
happen because we just don't have the
resource to run three planning
committees
thank you
councilman
uh thank you chairman
yeah I think a lot what I would say has
already been said and I understand that
members feel the need to be and
represent their Awards one of the my my
thing is though is we are the planning
Authority and we're not a parish council
or a Town Council and it's and we've got
to understand that
um I I know people are passionate about
planning and that's a lot of the reasons
why some of us are counselors It's not
the driving force for me to be a
counselor but I know it's a driving
force for a lot of other people to be a
counselor so I can understand that in
terms of where we are we're still at a
very precarious point in terms of how
people feel and we are very split as a
council on this particular decision I
would like I would like to forward a
recommendation to change little two
so that we change the number to a
15-seat planning committee
with eight substitutions
so therefore what we could have is we
could have substitutes if if someone
wanted to be on that particular planning
committee I also have a second
recommendation that if little two fails
that we postpone this for six months
until after the next election
so do I have a second for that
[Laughter]
I've got hands going up I don't know
what though with a second
are you second in councilor siddle
because you're seconding the the idea of
a committee of 15. right so so that is a
an amendment uh that we have and I'll
I'll again I'll take the the main report
and the amendment
um as as one debate to make things
easier
um councilor Lagan yeah thank you chair
um I'm gonna come out from completely
the opposite side of the fence
um The Evolution we don't know what
that's going to be like so I've got no
idea what we're talking about that at
this moment in time I think you've also
got a good report I've got a few um
problems with the report and a couple of
questions to ask on that under 3.2 it
talks about 90 of members having
training
um that's 27.9 members out of 31.
okay so we're not we're not that far
from The Mark as well when we talked
about reading the reports officers
reports 3.3 was burden the wording is
burden on members to read and it says a
burden you know they're very complex
things to read and you know once you get
your teeth into them that's actually
quite good
um I think Mr Mr Barker thanks for him
for his presentation but I've also I
bought stylists to recommend changes to
my house and I didn't take the
recommendations because they didn't fit
um 3.7 page 78 members agree to a
transformation review of the planning
service to improve operational
efficiency and resilience for the
delivery service delivery in the future
when
is something that I'm interested with
the diagram we actually did that because
I can't remember and I'm keeping a very
strict record on on the things that I'm
looking at now
this would be very um and I apologize
this comes out rather blunt officer
resources on page 80 CLT that's your job
that's your job to sort that out to sort
it out that's not my job that's your job
we're members
um if it's not working come up with a
strategy and put it to us as members so
that we can support you
um page 80 talks about budget savings
I'm not going to go with all the fear
about pre-determination because we've
had that thrown down on next all the
time and I think that what we do we
actually do really well and I was really
proud to see that report coming on
um with Mr Barker put of these planning
committees and more than 100 because it
means that everybody's actually sitting
there listening to you about
representing the their members in their
thinking but actually using the legal
framework to make decisions and we don't
have that we don't have that number of
um
I pay also say 7.7 that's that's not 10
but this was the thing when when it's
SNR in closing SNR had
um cost savings levied and it was
rejected that we should take that as a
central as well one planning committee
it didn't make the cut and I had the
chair over here who sanctioned that
so it says here budget savings reducing
from three area planning committees to
one committee would contribute 21 409
pounds per annum and a recurring budget
savings okay so 21 409 is equivalent to
690 quid and 61 Pence per year per
member 13 pound 28 per week to have
everybody go into a committee to
actually listen and to represent and I
said make decisions in a legal framework
or one pounds 89 Pence per day I don't
think that's enough to to take that away
um we also in closing you know there's
there's two points in closing the
implications on the report and I thank
the officers for the report because I'm
reading these reports with absolute
laser vision nowadays now that I've
started to understand the implications
if we don't get these decisions right it
talks about no internal customer change
applications to be priced in respected
time frames fairness consistency May
approve overall customer experience May
if it said it would by bam bam bam bam
bam I wouldn't be standing here arguing
to keep the area committees and plan is
not political y9 y15 have 31. if we're
going to do it once just have 31 members
no but I I I I I I say that you know
it's it's good that we've looked at it I
don't think the cost savings are enough
the emails that have come flooding in
today the people have knocked on my door
us on my house and have said yeah about
this thing so is it a motive issue I've
pushed that to one side and I've looked
at the fact of the matter we're better
off at this moment in time sticking with
what we've got and maybe in six 12
months when there is a new
Administration and a lot of us won't be
here then bring that to the table make
the decision and have a decision for the
next four years it represents thank you
well thank you chairman
um I'm a little bit more concentrating
on where it says officer resource and
there's a great big long list where it
says reminding officers to report
deadlines chasing officers report
deadlines and rather than going through
it all let me put it in highlighted
obviously offices require better
training if they're not putting
everything to committee and they're not
giving it to the committee clerks why
should that committee clerk have to
chase the individual officers we all
have to work with deadlines and within
deadlines one second thing the the
gentleman who did the presentation and
you please forgive me I'm rubbish at
names Steve Barker just for one thing
chairman I thought I would check some of
the facts and the information on here
because I'm a great one for believing
and double checking and I immediately
went to richmondshire
and the information there and it says
there is nine there is eight
um councilors per committee on the
planning committee well I actually
looked at their website and there's nine
Richard together is five members the
conservatives three and the green and
the independence is one with one vacant
to me that makes nine so I'm actually
questioning the accuracy of the report I
could go on but I ran out of time today
um I think it's um for everybody to it's
undemocratic to stop and I know he
turned around and said it's nothing to
do with democracy or somebody did
um it is democracy our residents expect
us I mean I'm going to say about Council
schemes when somebody turned around and
said something like you know you can't
speak or or I can't remember exactly
what he said and I think when Council
skins and I go to a planning committee
we very very rarely agree and that's
what makes the debate so I've got no
queries and qualms about not being able
to speak in my own word I trust my own
judgment I go to planning training I
listen and read the officer's reports
and I don't see it's a hardship to run
it reading any page papers I mean many
of us today have spent God knows all day
reading every piece of detail chairman
and finally you'll be pleased to know
there are other things which I won't go
on because other members have got
something to say it says impact on
customers okay at the bottom
implications no external customer change
applications would be processed in the
expected time scales
if there would be change danger
residents would have to if they want to
speak any committee would have to come
up here and I also don't agree with the
political makeup of it we're not
supposed to be political who says who's
going to sit on that committee we all
know what's going to happen after the
elections and people are naive if they
think that that presentation is going to
solve everybody's problems because I
certainly don't and I will not be
supporting the officer's recommendations
thank you councilor Sam
um members we this is going to be a long
debate so would would you please not
repeat or try not to repeat what other
members
have said
councilor Hull
thank you very much
it's always a bit worrying when
something as important as this comes
just before Christmas
so they always will unaware to me again
I'm sorry I'm repeating it but it's so
undemocratic and it it's to me it's it's
about what we all come on the committee
for is part of our our being here and um
with with people local people and it
that's what we fight for is what we want
in our country and our you know our part
of the country I'm really against it and
I'm really sad that it's been brought up
thank you Council Council skins
thank you I'm going to be brutally
honest here and tell you that I hate
planning I find it confusing difficult
deeply frustrating it's often a hiding
to nothing because the system is so
biased towards developers going with
this proposal could make most council's
lives easier
but I think we should keep the system we
have it feels more democratic it's
closer to the people affected Burnham
people for example prefer to attend
decisive planning meetings in Burnham
where their built environment actually
is where they actually live
pulling it all into a nine-person
Central Committee in Malden will just
serve to alienate more people increasing
suspicions about what is going on behind
closed doors or at least doors that are
harder to open because it involves a
one-hour round-trip plus the meeting
it is another barrier to public
participation another barrier to the
feeling of openness in a world of
confusion and suspicion
to my mind the big well let me go to the
next point the to me democracy is really
important in planning I say this in the
knowledge that some people don't think
that it is and use the argument to
support the destruction of the area
committees as we have just heard from Mr
Barker the whole point of having
councilors on committees on the area
committees is to ensure that planning is
democratic and is seen to be Democratic
even if the decisions have to be guided
by policy which of course itself is
created democratically and my
understanding is that we can Advocate at
area planning if we declare we won't
vote
the more local planning more local that
planning meetings are the better the
more planning training and the better
planning training the better the area
committee committees are a rare thing
and a good thing we should be proud of
them existing concerns can be addressed
by better training about the law the
appeals process our own policies
particularly and the risk of
predetermination it ain't broke don't
fix it
councilor keys
thank you Council chairman um I'm a
businessman and yeah obviously I'm here
to save money but 95 of my inbox is all
to do with planning I like my fellow
Ward member it is one of the main
reasons I'm on the planning I might be
quiet at these sort of meetings but if
you come to Northwest I'm certainly very
vocal at Northwest and I'll be careful
of what I say here but what happens in a
back street in Burnham have I really got
any interest in a lot of conversion no
more than someone in Burnham has got any
interest in a conservatory in Rookery
lying in great Tottenham and I've got
not a lot I work full time I know a lot
of us here do to come here we could be
sitting here with 14 applications
13 of them might be to do with Burnham
South mid stuff some other Ward the last
one might be to mine I've got to sit
here and listen to all that vote on it
and I'm sorry I'm totally dead against
that thank you councilor Bell
thank you Mr chairman I want to Echo
what I've heard from cancer stand wagon
skeins and the councilor Hull but I just
want to speak very briefly on the role
of overview and scrutiny on this because
I think it's very relevant and I'd
actually like to thank cancer fluka for
his motions because what they have led
to it's really quite an intense and
in-depth piece of work being done by
officers on behalf of Olivia and
scrutiny to do exactly the things that
counselor schemes mentioned to improve
training to improve policy to improve
the way that the current system works
because there's always a need for
improvement there's not such a
difference between appeals lost by a
delegated level and member level but
these improvements that officers have
worked really hard on for the overview
and scrutiny committee certainly do not
entail cutting the area committees and
having one committee thank you
councilor Swain
thank you chairman I'm
I certainly don't think we should be
sort of preempting and preparing for
being Amalgamated and that's hardly a
reason
um when it comes to
the matches that councilor Keys
mentioned we're talking about
um
um decisions which
major decisions are going to go to the
district planning
um significant decisions would be for
this area committee
um the question then comes down to the
individual
specific perhaps hold applications and
so on which are more a matter of
delegated
um responsibilities to officers and
dealings with Ward members
um and discussion about callings
so that provided there's an adequate
decision on call a system on College
then
um even the most minor planning
application could be dealt with if
um the member was prepared to call it in
um
on the question of
um
planning officers uh that is an entirely
separate issue I think would be
obviously so badly under staffed on
planning that that is a separate issue
to be addressed
um
and when it comes to the numbers on the
committee that comes down to why I
seconded uh councilor siddle's amendment
to this I do think
um a committee of 15 would allow not
only for the political balance that we
have to have but also for geographical
balance
um across the across the district
and the although this is being portrayed
and as a lot of the people who've um
approached members and complained about
it seeing it as quite
inevitably as a cost-saving measure I
don't see it as at all I think the
amount of money involved is not great it
is a matter of having consistency
um and
um
a call not a large call
um who are dealing with
um the planning matters in um uh what
should we say a rigorous and consistent
way that the plan people can see that it
is operating consistently
um and as far as one of the other
comments I think from counseling key uh
skins is concerned
um arguing on having completely
different views of these area committees
tends to mean that people are voting the
way they want to vote
um rather than paying enough attention
to planning law and the ldp and the
Council of policies there shouldn't be
all that all that smart scope
um so I I would very much I use I did
vote in favor of keeping the area
committees when just came out two years
ago but I'm I'm quite persuaded now that
we should move to a single committee
provided there are adequate details and
this is the recommendation three
um
about things like call-ins and
geographical spread and this sort of
thing thank you Council Spencer thank
you yeah
so um what I want to say is that whilst
I think there is arguably a need for a
reform of our planning decision making
process here and I do understand the
arguments regarding board member
advocacy
I also feel that this is not the right
proposal which is evidenced by the fact
that we're sitting in here trying to do
something really important on the hoof
now which I don't feel is right at all
um I feel this is not the right proposal
nor at the right time
if we move if we are to consider moving
to a single committee it would require
more than nine members in my opinion
which has already been said political
balance alone is not appropriate here
and as councilor Bell said ons have
already started to do a huge piece of
work on planning and decision making
reform and I do feel that's been
completely overlooked and sidelined in
this here tonight
an argument to support this proposal has
been made along the lines of Ward
members
um as our actors Ward members in
planning committees currently
um rather than in the interest of the
district if that's so can anyone hear
please tell me why there appears to be a
presumption that this would change under
the arrangements recommended this
evening
I don't believe it would
um planning process reform at this
Council given all the current
circumstances and there are really some
current circumstances which I'm not even
going to discuss here right now because
I don't think it's appropriate
requires significant workup I think we
haven't got the detail it isn't here and
I don't think it's appropriate for us to
stand here in the week before Christmas
or whatever it is on the clock now and
try and come up with something that's
going to be satisfactory to take forward
um
for change of this magnitude real
consultation with our towns and parishes
to ensure proper representation going
forward is also essential they are our
consultants and we do need to be at
least talking to them first this appears
to me to be a bit of a rush job push
forward in the last meeting before
Christmas and it seems to have served to
cause nothing more than further
hostility and Division and that does
concern me
in some ways I am reluctant to propose
another working group
and everyone knows and I'm sure from
what councilor fluke said earlier I am
one of the core of people who's at
almost every working always every always
at every working group
but it seems to me that this will likely
be the only way of achieving proper and
robust consultation with members on this
issue therefore I would like to propose
a setting up of a working group on the
planning decision-making process and I
also would like to say that that would
then give us something to leave the new
members who come in perhaps in May 2023
something that they can then consider as
new members but that I just put that
forward thank you chair councilor
Thompson
foreign
I thought councilor white was before me
and I think no I thought her hand was up
before mine but anyway okay thank you
um
um it's funny that term regulatory not
Democratic I say it all these kinds of
meetings and I just get blank stares but
I'm afraid it's a fact this is
not only in many ways I regret it this
is not about what our residents want we
are here to follow a regulatory process
just like licensing where we you know we
used to do that with three we still can
do that with three
we're here to consider the whole
District not our Ward yeah we're here to
consider the ldp which applies to the
whole District not just our Ward not to
be just interested in what goes on
immediately around us
I'm afraid it is blindingly obvious
quite often that my committee Northwest
that people haven't read the reports
haven't taken them in
and I'm afraid you know our last meeting
was two call-ins and they both went with
the officer recommendation and it was
over in 23 minutes
what's the point
sorry I thought you finished no I'm
sorry I
was drawing breath and I'm afraid one of
those applications it was blindingly
obvious that you know the report had not
been read or understood sorry I'm afraid
you know and I I often see reports
had not been read or have not been
understood uh it does happen I've got a
lot of members here read everything
diligently
but I'm afraid it's not it's not
Universal and one other thing is nearly
all the overturned certainly my
committee but I think across the council
as well uh they are overturned for
approval so these decisions don't ever
go to appeal
thank you
councilor dueck
yeah yeah I think chairman
well councilor schemes has no decently
said basically everything that I wanted
to say in the first time
but I got my half I got my half yet to
go so sorry we'll have to put up with
that
um
light counts the keys the bulk of
contact I get from the general public is
on planning it yesterday it was somebody
who phoned me up said what on Earth do I
do to get my planning application
accepted by
um
by the officers it just keeps being
rejected a few weeks ago it was what do
I do to prevent my neighbor building a
monstrosity in his back Garden that's
going to affect my life and so it goes
on all the time
but unlike council Mrs Thompson there is
I believe democracy to be had in
planning without any detriment to the
planning process at all I'd like to give
you three examples the first one was a
few months ago with Burnham Rugby Club
who wanted to build an extension on the
existing Sports Center down on the
playing fields at Burnham on Crouch the
officers recommended refusal
because of poor design and poor
architectural quality
members took the view
that actually the existing building is
poor design and poor architectural
quality so really it didn't make a lot
of difference
but consequently we approved the
application I don't believe there was
any loss to anyone in that there's no
loss to planning department no loss to
local residents or anything it was a
sensible decision made by members which
would not have been made by by officers
another one was in tillingham vicarage
lane recently where
an old conversion of a shed to a
dwelling many years ago the applicants
wanted to demolish it and build a period
design Cottage
again the conservation officer was in
favor of it but planning officers were
against but members took the view that
it was going to be good for the area
good for the applicants no reason not to
prove so we approved it the third one is
very recent
and actually
itself is a decision that was made last
week
the application
was for the author community at Bradwell
which I suspect most if not all members
here
know what it is where it is why it is
the application was for the erection of
a wind turbine of up to 32 meters
overall height to tip
the Thunder Community Easton Road
Bradwell on scene
officers refused that application I
won't go through all the reasons but the
first reason is the development as a
result of the height size and position
of the wind turbine proposed would be a
visually incongruous element within this
flat open rural Coastal landscape
to the detriment of the character and
appearance of the area contrary to
policies
S8 D4 and D1 of the approved modern
District local development plan there
are three more reasons for refusal which
are all basically around the same thing
now members all laugh just now because
they know like I know if you stand at
the afford a community and look
Southeast
[Music]
130 meter high turbines dominating the
landscape turn 180 degrees and look
across the river and at St Joseph there
are another six look East
and there are hundreds of the
monstrosities
clearly members in this case know far
far more than the officers concerned who
must could never have visited the site
and must not know anything about your
thunder Community or its application
that is somebody who just said local
knowledge we need it we need it in our
planning we need to keep the system
we've got as somebody else said it ain't
broke don't fix it thank you
Mr chairman how can I follow that but um
I will quickly follow it um just to say
that uh I chair strategy and resources
and we had a report an appendix 3 come
to us uh PGA committee recommended that
we not remove the area planning
committees and my committee also
um advised that or agreed to keep
appendix 3 which was to retain three
area committees it was only saving 64
000 a year office is recommended that it
stay on the appendix 3 that it wasn't
worth rejecting and yet here we are
again we don't we won't go with strategy
and resources we won't go with PJ oh
we'll bring it to council again so
that's the first thing so then we move
on here and thank you to Mr Barclay for
um get back for giving his report but um
my question is uh we go on about the
majors well Majors that aren't decided
by um area committees they decided by
districts that's got nothing to do with
us on the miners could officers of Mr
Barker tell me the percentage difference
between officer delegated decisions that
are allowed to appeal as opposed to area
plug-in committees that are allowed to
appeal because I'm pretty sure that the
percentage of
um area planning committee overturns is
less than officer overturns that's the
first one the second one is the cost of
64 000. that is amazing value three
committees and it only cost 64 000. the
the residents I've but over three years
the residents I've spoken to think this
is brilliant value
um I'm playing I'm interested that some
of the members don't think they they
they listen to their residents they
don't listen to their Parish councils I
do I don't always vote with them but I
listen to them I was elected to stand up
and make the difficult decisions yep
not always popular but I've always done
what I think to be right I've always
stood up and I've always voted the way I
think's correct and as for Northwest I
now have my ldp book with me with my
piling policies and it's funny but when
we've got policies to approve them like
employment's important yours is like no
no no we don't like that policy we're
going with this policy it's the members
gift to use the policies as we see fit
so I'm gonna wait and hear what the
percentages are
um because I think these are right and
with Devolution the area planning police
will be gone anyway let's make them most
of them while we can and my last point
is we go on about democracy I have never
ever voted on planning along a political
party line I have voted under my own
decision and it's never political and I
don't think any member votes on planning
along a party line for one it's illegal
and two we make our own decisions it's
vital we keep this is vital for members
and it's vital for members of the public
and uh it's it's so important we keep it
every four years this comes up because
officers don't like it I mean we've got
a thing here that later on where we they
want more planning resources well if
we're going to do away with the area
committees we don't need any more
planning offices do we because it only
everything will be underdelegated so
let's keep them
um
I think Mr Dodson wants to
um say something on on those last uh or
your earlier comments I think thank you
chairman I think it's come up a couple
of times and it was it was just to
clarify the point around the appendix 3
that was referred to to strategy and
resources
that was not included as as one of the
savings but as I explained at the start
of this report the report was prompted
by the internal audit report as well as
the wider efficiencies so it's a much
broader Point than the budget saving and
it wasn't appropriate to bring It
Forward on two fronts hence why it
wasn't brought forward as a saving it
was brought forward through this route
so it's a clarification that there's
there's not a conflict between the two
issues councilor helm
thank you Mr chairman a bit of History
I've been chairman of election and
Parish Council and chairman of the
danger group parishes which as you know
is a huge amount of price process their
most concern is planning
and if we look back the people that vote
for us their most important thing to
them is their house and their
surrounding area
and that's why I think we should keep
the area planning committees I've also
invested two thousand pound in keeping
it Burnham so we have the recording and
the internet facility to run it there
so we can get rid of the council offices
and save money and use that equipment to
have meetings anywhere thank you
councilor Hood
thank you chairman uh goodness me what a
lot of electioneering going on tonight
um
I'm very pleased to hear councilor white
Advocate Independence
um that was the first point so I will be
brief
um I'll just go down the bullet points
here I don't think we should wait I
think that we should decide with
ourselves as experienced counselors
rather than having all the new
counselors coming and decide for that I
think Mr Mr Bay came up welcome some
very good points I don't think there's
going to be any lack of democratic
representation it's still go it's still
going to be allowed members can go along
actually I would welcome the opportunity
to go to a meeting and speak my mind
openly either in support of it or not in
support of it and I think as a Wards
member that's exactly what we should be
doing I think that there are far too
many planning matters referred to the
committee
um and I think that there are too many
decisions that are two varies
um I think the meetings are often
canceled indeed
um Center was canceled yesterday uh due
to lack of business my mailbox is full
of counselors who are not happy not
members of the public
and I don't think I don't think that
that will change I agree there should be
no political balance but I would also
support councilor civil's proposal for
the fifth engine thank you
councilor Stevens
who's the last speaker
thank you
you've had a
goal
what was the 3.3 business
sorry Council statements
thank you chair
um we've heard from councilor Duo can
counselor white about various sort of
anecdotal things that have happened in
planning meetings but I didn't hear
anything that wouldn't happen just the
same in the new setup so there will
still be you've got one policy that
suggests we should say yes and you've
got another one that says we should say
no we'll always have that and that's why
people have to look and debate and
examine and put the weighted balance and
all the rest of it onto onto a decision
it doesn't make any difference what kind
of committee it is yeah and counselor
dewick spoke about decisions that
Bradwell well I can't see that that
decision would be any different if it's
in an area committee or a district
committee or a centralized committee
you've got an officer's recommendation
you don't think it makes sense so you
overturn it it's just the same
we've heard about how what a very long
way away Burnham is half an hour to
Malden I get that it's half an hour for
me from tolesbury as well it's no
different that you know it's not like a
different world south south of the river
um I have been to Burnham thank you I
enjoyed it please members
time I think we councilor Fleming made a
very good point that we have too few
planners it may or may not be excuse me
good value for money it could be better
value for money but we haven't got
enough people and we don't seem to be
able to buy enough people and we will
end up having to spend more because
we'll be getting in Consultants so I
don't think it's just about the money
um I think we need to have more than
nine maybe 12 maybe 15. I think for
having a political balance as well as a
geographic is important
um I sit on Northwestern and there are
seven conservatives and two Independents
and that does feel unbalanced to me at
times now of course if all the
conservatives vote in One Direction and
the independence vote the other way
everyone will say I was Voting with well
that has happened everyone will say that
had nothing to do with it
everyone will say it didn't have
anything to do with it and I can't prove
otherwise and I'm not going to try and
prove otherwise but it doesn't look good
to the public and I get
I get residents mailing me saying that
was a whitewash that's their opinion
that's their perception we can't take
that away from people that you know we
may say it's wrong but that is genuinely
somebody's perception it's not a good
look
um
I don't think any of my other notes I
think everything else has been covered
thank you I'll let you uh uh because
your 3.3 issue might have been questions
to Mr barter I'm grateful Jen um
chairman I'll go straight three minutes
no more that Gemini you've said a
president because I've been timing
members on average have been speaking
four minutes and 32 seconds
um Gemma can I take you immediately to
page 78
um chairman Pace 78 plan advisory
service report legal resource
um I'm heartened at the monitoring
office uh I've got uh the resources to
do this but only for one committee uh
with the greatest respect I don't know
whether or not they're planning train
but if this doesn't go ahead then we
clearly need to to review the
establishment there to make sure that
we're getting best value because they've
clearly got time and chairman the
guidance for best practice just below
most councils have a delegation rate of
over 90 percent
Malden was around 80. well chairman
anybody that's read the report that went
to council uh went to strategy and
resources on the uh 29th of September
and I I do hope Mr bark has read
everything
um it says there applications decisions
delegated and it lists all the councils
and I'm pleased to say that Malden was
actually 97. so 97 not 80. so I'm not
sure where that comes from the overview
and scrutiny committee we've we've dealt
with inefficiencies running meetings and
meetings being canceled with any
meetings will be canceled but at the
time they're canceled the reports
haven't been written anyway all that's
been reported all that's done is the
validation and chairman I think
councilor white asked about uh appeal
decisions and and chairman this went to
uh PG a on the 29th of September so I'm
not making this up it's almost there uh
I mean I presume Mr bark has read this
but he seemed to add an awful lot of
weight to the fact that members were
making poor decisions uninformed poor
decisions so chairman let's have a look
at this appeal decision is allowed 20.
17 were delegated three were decisions
to overturn a committee and they were
allowed so it strikes me as though
members are doing quite well with what
they're supposed to be doing and then
when we look at appeals dismissed uh Mr
Mr quotes I hate you to miss this when
when uh when we'd start looking at
appeals dismissed there were 21 in this
period
19 were delegated decisions
one was a decision overturned at
committee so you've got one wrong and
one was a decision where the officers
and the committee agreed so really out
of all of that there was only one appeal
that went down because of members
Behavior so I don't really get that
chairman and then just finally when I
can find my asterisks is when we start
talking about
um appeal costs I mean the appeal costs
this great appeal costs are 215 000 plus
her own costs which are about twenty
thousand I think 235 000
um it says on here that this was
um Southeast committee overturned an
office officer's recommendation but it
wasn't it was the district plan
committee where they come together I I
really feel so much of the information
uh in this report uh isn't quite right
it's either not right or the information
that was given to PGA was wrong
I don't know which but I feel very
uncomfortable making decisions although
I do believe the PGA stuff is correct
but chairman we have a choice you know
well I don't want any more working
groups they cost a fortune uh you know
we need to uh make a decision chairman
and I would propose chairman I would
propose the contrary to the officer's
recommendation that we stay
well it's already an amendment well
chairman will deal with the amendment
chairman but one thing I would say is
this is that somebody said Don't Leave
It to the uh the new intake of
counselors or the new Administration but
the director of strategy performance and
governance has already said that one of
the most important documents other than
the local development plan that this
Council produces the court put plan will
not be agreed until the new
Administration is in place so based on
that alone
I think that we should at the least
defer it but at best at best not support
these recommendations
everybody has had a say we've taken over
an hour
um which is about what I expected
um councilor siddle has made an
amendment
uh no councilor siddle has made an
amendment you can only have one
Amendment at a time
no no you can't do that
you're you're your amendment was for 15.
uh so I'll put that
um with eight substitutes uh without
substitutes yes
is that second they didn't recordly vote
Yes
yes
okay
um Tara uh we're we're voting on a
committee a single committee chairman I
was I was seconding councilor siddles
proposal not second in the vote no so
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um the the amendment is that there's a
single planning committee of 15 with
eight
substitutes
uh Tara will you call the roll please
yes traveling thank you remember the
tickets for against
the battle oh
thank you councilor Bell against
The Voice
abstain
four
Council Direct
against
the Durham
four
four
thanks for subscribing for
cat
games
four
against
four
[Music]
against
the keys against
against
Council Morley
against
Shaughnessy four
that's the sigil
four
that's the schemes abstain
that's respectfully against
the stone against
Council Stevens
just too many bites on oh sorry
four
thank you counselor stilts against
four
okay four
Council Miss White
against
the results about uh 12 4 13 again
um
uh I'm I'm reminded
um that uh
uh once as leader
um I lost the vote by one to go to a
single planning committee
um
I was starting to sweat a bit there
um so now we we have the uh um we come
back to the recommendations as they stay
under one two and three
um I should have asked uh the leader to
sum up with a view of the I'd like to
propose that we stayed with the three
area planning committees if I get a
second well
you've got to vote against a
recommendation
or the recommendations
uh right we'll go straight to that then
uh Miss bird
um
uh the
four or against on the recommendations
uh contained on what page is it page 77.
oh can we take the vacuum
recommendations
I'll take them all together because of
the time thank you
thank you chairman time plays no part in
democracy
can I just say I'm looking forward to
Leader's questions together chairman
I'm sorry to interrupt I'd just like to
give notice of motion that should this
next one fail I will put a motion that
all applications go to one committee the
district planning committee
I I don't think I don't think there is
no argument I don't think you you can do
that I think you have to Once once this
uh vote has been taken you can't put an
amendment down can you Simon no but you
can put forward
okay we're now voting for or against
keeping the planning committees yes so
we're saying
no no you're voting you're voting
against the coming to one planning
committee
Miss bird Miss Bird please call the roll
you're voting for The substantive motion
on the recommendations contained on the
report I've got the leader indicating
now well chairman I wasn't allowed to uh
sum up as you quite rightly said so I've
lost the opportunity to comment on what
came forward in the previous debate uh
so I didn't have the advantage of making
my points known therefore chairman what
I'm hearing that I could move a motion
regarding as long as it's been a report
and councilor said or was allowed to do
that regarding the number changing to
nine I would then like to propose
chairman that we actually do go with 15
as council Mrs Thompson has said on a
single commission I don't see why I
cannot do it 31 sorry 31 sorry 31 31 beg
your pardon
I believe no I believe that's what the
monitoring officer has just said well in
that case we'll we'll vote for my motion
which is to stay with the status quo
members I I've
believe that the
consensus of this
is quite is going to be quite clear
I won't consider any more amendments or
motions I will put these recommendations
as contained on the report if you agree
them you're for if you're against them
you're against
uh Miss bird
against
abstain
if we're voting on the recommendations
on your table
sorry four
against
four
that's the edge against
because I don't agree with little two
thank you
quite I agree with little one two and
three so against
that's the head four
against
the hole against
priestara
against
sorry against
four
four
against
me against
the stone against
four
against
Council three
abstain on the grounds we haven't
considered the report primary
four
sorry could you repeat that that was a
four please
against
the results
right that
um that is lost
uh and we'll move on to a schedule of
meetings uh on page 80.
9 to 94 uh and I think there might be
two options there there's only one
option that we'll choose in leader
uh well chairman yes um in light of that
decision there is only one option now
and the schedule of meetings really I'm
going to go straight to the
recommendation for 2023 municipally be
approved and set out in the appropriate
appendices appendix rather chairman with
area planning committees thank you
Council fluka chairman I mean I'm sure
there was a time when the what we used
to call the program committees used to
meet eight times a year and that still
managed to dive into the uh dovetail
into Council but it seems to me if my
mathematics is correct that at the
moment the strategy and resources and
PGA I've only got six meters and and it
seems to me that the agendas of these
committees seem to be getting bigger and
bigger and and I do know that you know
it's really important that they do
dovetail into the business of council
but not everything has to dovetail in
and I just think you know we're getting
to the stage you know I'm seriously not
going to keep talking to the half past
10 but you know I'm going to bring the
whole forward a proposal but it's too
late you know we've got PGA strategy and
resources we've got the officers here
tonight I mean how they are managing to
all four of them look so attentive I
don't know it's getting late I'm getting
tired everyone's getting a bit grumpy
um and I just think that we when we look
at this scheduler meetings chairman we
should
um perhaps try and spread them a bit and
maybe you know if we've got time Mr
Dodson can have a look at that and also
chairman I I don't know how people feel
about it but
is it really necessary to start meetings
uh 7 31 and 7 p.m and the other thing
chairman concerns me enormously with
some of these meetings and the
scheduling is the overall agendas
because we get to the stage where
chairman you might miss my next gem
thank you very much chairman um well I
was also I forgotten what I was going to
say but chairman
okay
well I think Mr I'm I'm listening Mr um
the benefit of that must be very
important but chairman we get to the
stage where we need to look at the way
these these agendas are structured look
we've got two officers sitting here been
here since half past seven it's half
past ten they're only here because of p
and c I mean can we not have a look at
this and try and get the PNC on early so
that we can get the officers home early
and if not necessary meet earlier this I
mean you know we've got a duty of care
of all of our stuff well if we did what
was this agenda item we've probably been
a half hour earlier and thank you
councilor fluke chairman now it's half
past 10 can I propose that this meeting
is adjourned Sani die
um uh it's my discretion uh uh chairman
uh uh councilman Fluker
um
do do members do members uh accept that
that
um schedule of meetings
oh the leader wants to say something
well chairman yeah I mean the two
officers that Council fluke has refer to
I think they're here for a gender item
number 20 and I'm wondering if that
could be brought up
now they they uh
um
I'm just dealing with the scheduler
meetings now
do members agree the schedule of
meetings
thank you right uh now obviously it's
gone 10 o'clock so we don't do 16.
um
sorry councilor stem chairman chairman
it's half past ten
yeah but we need we need at least the um
um chairman I have to leave I'm terribly
sorry but I do have to go my apologies
has a duty of care to its staff and the
staff have a duty occur to members you
can't be at her past Ted and expect to
make informed decisions
well will members allow me to do just
one more report in in PNC it's leaders
questions no no that's not in PNC this
is subversive democracy in the
Constitution I know what the
Constitution says to the leader not
after 10 o'clock chairman can you
imagine what that sounds like to anybody
that's listening to this I I
I know exactly what it sounds like it
sounds like the chairman is rolling
um
I've got lots of hands up what are they
saying can I do one more
time
oh I'm not I'm not opposing the meeting
I'm going to exclude the oppressive
public and do one more item chairman I I
may have proposed we have had the two
officers remaining here and that's the
point I was trying to make and I believe
unless they tell me to the country that
they are here for a gender item number
20 under PNC commercial project update
yes they're both saying yes chairman
Mr chairman this cannot be
democratically correct we've got members
leaving left right and center the time
we've been here three hours the fact is
they've crammed a huge amount of
business into this agenda and far far
more than should be expected of us
we should be allowed to do these bit
this business properly and correctly
when when we've all got time and effort
to think well I've got to be up at six
in the morning for work as I know of
others it is not fair on members and
officers to carry on with this now
right I I get the message
uh
I'll now close the meeting
at uh 22 33.
[Music]
um
Sorry Miss bird I'm sorry I'm I'm
adjourning
all right